Oh,
hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Welcome back!
Oh my gosh, uh, I like passed out so fast after...
Well, not after the sponsor stream yesterday, but like after I ate dinner... did I eat... yeah, after I ate... I was like, did I eat dinner?
Yes, after I ate dinner.
After I ate dinner, um, I like, I was like, I'm gonna take a nap.
I'm tired.
I'm, I'm, I'm gonna take a nap.
I'm gonna set up an alarm.
I, I need you guys to know, I, I snoozed on my, on my phone alarm ten times, I think.
It felt like ten times.
To the point where I...
I think, um, I vaguely remember this, but like, um, one of my parents went into my room and like, just took my phone and shut it off.
Like...
Because, because, you know, every, every ten to fifteen minutes, it just kept, you know, ringing.
The alarm just kept ringing, cause I keep snoozing, cause I couldn't wake, I couldn't properly wake up.
So then like, one of my parents just went into my room, they had it, and they went into my room and finally shut my alarm off so that I would never snooze again.
I was so tired.
I'm still tired.
Oh my god.
Um, needless to say, uh, I'm gonna be taking two rest days in a row.
So Sunday and Monday, I'm out.
I'm out.
Um, let me, I need to, where's my...
Let me open the window.
It always gets like, I think like ever since I got my, uh, new PC, it's like a lot stronger now.
Um...
Um, it's a lot stronger now.
So like, because of that, it does generate heat more often.
It does generate a lot, I feel like it generates a lot more heat now.
So like, because it's like a super buff PC.
But like, um, so now it's like extra stuffy in my room.
So I need to like always open the window.
Give me a sec guys.
I don't, I have to close my window at night because I don't want bugs in my room.
Um, give me a sec.
No.
Okay.
How I open the window is like, super unconventional.
Because like, it's one of those windows where it has two locks.
So the lock, one of the locks is at the top.
Um, so what I do is that I grab the lock.
So I get the bottom lock.
And then what I do to get the top lock is that I take the ends of the blinds.
And then I just like, I use it to poke the...
I take the ends of the blinds.
And then I pull it up and just use it as like a pointer stick.
And just to unlock the lock.
And that's how I do it because I'm not tall enough.
It's a really tall lock.
It's really tall.
Um, but yeah, that's how I do it.
Okay guys, I might actually need coffee.
Give me a second.
I was like, I'm like, oh no, this game.
Somebody was like, you should not be playing this game while tired.
And I was like, oh shit, you're right.
This game is actually hard.
Give me a sec.
I will grab coffee real quick.
Alright.
I've got my canned coffee.
My...
I'm a canned coffee connoisseur.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, sorry.
I thought I put my headphone.
Oh my gosh, why is my headphone so...
Oh no, did I accidentally...
I broke my headphone in the middle.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Alright, it's sort of...
It's not fixed.
Oh no.
I got to buy new headphones.
I'm a mess right now.
I don't know
what headphones this is.
Oh, I'm a mess.
I can't even open my canned coffee.
Give me...
Okay, now I open it.
Okay.
You can hear the strength.
I'm strong as fuck.
Okay.
I open it.
I'm going to have to order new headphones after this stream.
I just started and I'm a mess.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
So, uh, but yeah, it has been a lot.
It's been a lot.
Thank you Super Chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, My Solutions having an alarm volume so loud, I almost get panic attacks when waking up.
That's the thing.
I do have a very loud alarm.
It's a classic like So, that's a sad alarm.
But, like, I've been using that alarm for my whole life.
Like, ever since I got an iPhone?
Um, that like my body can just be, you know?
...has trained itself to like, uh...
...to like... what's the word?
...that I got used to it.
Like, it's not... I'm so fucked on a real fire alarm.
I... I once slept through a fire alarm.
It's that bad!
Luckily, it was like a drill, a practice fire alarm.
Like, it wasn't a real fire alarm.
Cause I be really fucked cause I live in a very, very... I live on like, the higher floors...
...um... at my apartment.
So like, I be very, very fucked.
...
I... I...
Okay, not gonna lie, I'm gonna say, I don't understand.
I don't know if this is like, an Asian thing.
But like, I actually... I honestly... I... I don't underst...
Oh, so my... I don't know why, every time like, I start stream...
...um... my chat dies.
I don't know if it's like, an OBS thing or whatever.
Uh... but it's been like...
Like, if I like, swap from this scene, my chat just disappears.
And I don't know if it's like, an OBS...
Um... an OBS bug or whatever.
But it's happening a lot frequently.
Um... but... um...
Wait, where was I on topic?
Uh...
Oh yeah, okay, I don't know if it's an Asian thing.
But like... um...
Like... I... like...
I always... like, I... I... Everytime...
We like... you know, like...
...um... my parents are like...
We like, move somewhere.
Or like, for hotels and stuff, They're always like, Oh, we gotta get the highest floors.
Because the higher the floor you are, the more important you are.
Or, like the more...
like the better the room is, the better the place is.
But like... I... I don't underst..
...the reason why.
Like... I don't... I don't... I don't...
I don't understand the reasoning.
I'd rather it be like... is it less noise?
Is that it?
Higher is better.
I guess it's like less bug.
Is that really... is it like less bugs or what?
I don't understand.
Closer... I like something... it's closer to heaven.
I don't understand... I don't understand.
Cause i rather be closer to the floor.
Because um... I feel... it's just... I don't know... If there's a fire alarm, I don't have to walk down so many stairs.
Like...方." Oh, less noise from the streets?
I guess so.
I guess that makes sense.
I couldn't understand it at first.
But I think...
It's good that you guys are smarter than me because I would be fine living closer to the ground.
Like, I don't really care too much about...
I guess like... I'm so used to living in apartments that's like at higher floors.
That like I didn't realize it also potentially means less bugs.
Which is a good thing because I have my windows open.
And like bugs that made it to my floor, like they deserve to be in here.
Because like I live really... I live like really high up.
So if they manage to fly all the way up here, then like good for them.
You know what?
They made it.
It's like a pilgrimage.
They finally made it.
They won only...
Yeah, they won only up.
They deserve to be here.
Lusagi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, it's your first super chat too!
Thank you!
Also, I'm sorry I didn't read super chats yesterday during the sponsor stream.
I got so absorbed into Neopets that like...
I forgot all about like reading the super chats.
I'm so sorry.
There were so many first time super chatters too.
But thank you so much for the super chat, Lusagi.
Thank you, thank you.
Towards your new headphones!
So happy to be here for Digimon.
Who's your favorite Digimon?
Oh, I talked about it, but it's Betsumon.
If you're talking about joke Digimon, it's Betsumon.
But like if you're talking about actual my favorite Digimon, I would say it's like...
It's Gatomon.
All the Digimon in... all the Digimon starters for Tamers.
Because they're all peak.
I think Digimon Tamers had all the peak Digimon designs.
And I like...
And I think Patamon is ugly.
Everyone was always saying like, oh, Patamon is like the mascot Digimon.
Just like how Pikachu is the mascot Pokemon.
But I'm like, why Patamon?
He's so fucking ugly!
I don't understand!
He's not cute at all!
I think he's just a...
If you take away his wings, he's just a giant potato with legs.
He's like a giant thumb with legs, if you think about it.
Like you just... if you take your thumb out and you put wings on it, that's Patamon.
That's...
No, people would say that Patamon...
You guys were like, no, the mascot is Agumon.
No, back then... back then, everybody would say like Patamon is like the cute mascot for Digimon back then.
And they would make like so much merch for it.
Because like, Patamon is like... was like a lot easier to like merchandise.
Which I understand, because it's literally a thumb with wings.
But like, back then it was Patamon.
Where they kept like pushing Patamon everywhere.
Now it's Agumon.
Because like now they're like, oh, Agumon was actual... the actual like main mascot for Digimon.
But even then, like...
They would make so much merch for it.
I would have liked to have Patamon back then.
Because they're like, Patamon is the main character.
They would push Patamon everywhere in NA.
And I thought he was like the ugliest... one of the ugliest Digimon in the franchise.
Don't... don't...
You just hate me because I'm right.
You just... it's exactly... it's a... it's a bean with wings.
It's a giant thumb with wings.
It's not even cute.
It's not even...
They booed her because she's right.
There were so many more cuter Digimon than Patamon.
Okay, Digimon...
Season 1.
Like...
Okay, I have to admit though, like...
Oh my god, her... Patamon is so fucking ugly compared to everybody else.
Like...
I'm just... I'm just looking at... I'm looking at like...
The Digimon...
The Digimon variants in Season 1.
I mean, look at this!
Alright!
Compared to every other Digimon there for the DigiDestined.
Like, look at all the Digimon for the DigiDestined.
Like... Okay, Agumon, I would admit, it's not like everybody's favorite.
Because like, even though he's like a dino...
Um...
He's like a very...
He has like a...
The chest of a human...
Like a...
A chest of a human.
So like, I can understand where people are like...
Um... Agumon is like not their thing.
Because... Honestly, for me, it was also bad to me too.
I never liked Agumon.
Because like, his chest is literally like...
Uh...
Like that of like...
Um...
Of like a person that might have like let themselves go a little bit.
Uh...
Yeah, he's got the...
He's got the dad bod.
I would admit, he's got the dad bod.
And...
So like, I wasn't like a huge fan of Agumon.
Um...
So...
I wasn't... Okay, I wouldn't say I didn't like Agumon.
Like, I have...
I was just like indifferent to Agumon.
I hated Patamon because they kept pushing Patamon...
As like the main cute man.
As like the mascot of Digimon.
And I hated his design.
Because I thought like Patamon's design was like so ugly.
And I still do.
Um...
Like, Patamon plushies aren't even cute.
Like...
I...
It...
Okay.
Official Patamon plushie is not even cute.
Like I...
Like, okay.
This is like what they sold back then.
For like...
Um...
They were like selling...
Like, you know...
Like...
It's very hard to get Digimon merch.
I'll just say.
I remember like back then.
It was so difficult to get Digimon merch in the West.
Because like Digimon was not popular at all.
And...
Like...
It was popular but not as popular as Pokemon.
Because like...
You know...
Pokemon was here first.
In...
Um...
In the West.
Even though I would say the anime series is so much better.
Versus...
Uh...
Versus Pokemon.
Um...
And I feel like they just didn't have like a lot of good games.
They just...
The biggest downside for Digimon in the West is that they didn't have a lot of good games.
But like...
Look at this ugly fucker.
They still don't...
It's really difficult to make Digimon games.
But like...
Um...
Like...
Oh my god.
He's so ugly.
Like...
I just never liked how he looked.
I...
But he...
He's so cute.
You're...
Okay.
Like...
But like...
You're...
You're just mad because you...
You know there's like better...
Like Terriormon...
It should've...
Terriormon...
I bet you like...
Um...
If Terriormon was in Season 1...
Like...
He would be the...
He would've beaten Pikachu.
Terriormon would've 100% beaten Pikachu if he was created in Season 1.
Like...
He has everything.
Everything that Pikachu wishes!
They made Pikachu...
Pikachu used to be a fat fuck and then like he got skinnier and skinnier into like Terrarium on bods like
Okay, Pikachu fat Pikachu, okay, there you go like Okay, let's see.
I mean there's like the evolution like look at him.
This is like Terrarium on had that body before Pikachu became skinny
This is literally Terriormon!
Are your eyes okay?
Bad Pikachu, my boy.
Alright, Terrier... okay, Digimon Tamers.
When did Digimon Tamers come out?
Digimon Tamers came out in 2001!
Skinny Pikachu was 2010!
You guys are like, but I used to love Fat Pikachu.
Yeah, but it was... oh my gosh, okay.
Um, wait...
Pikachu... okay, the reason... I feel like one of the reasons why...
Oh my god, okay...
I looked up... I looked up...
I looked up Fat Pikachu plush and I got this.
I'm sorry, I should be playing the game, but like...
I'm a little bit too absorbed right now.
And... and... and...
Pikachu versus Terriormon.
But look at... look at...
Look at this absolute unit, though.
This is unrelated to my conversation, but like, I really want...
I really want this...
I want this... what the fuck?
Can I buy this?
Where can I buy one of these Fat Pikachu plushies?
Wait, I wanna buy one too!
Oh my god!
No!
They don't scum!
I want the Mochi Pikachu plushie!
No!
They don't sell these guys any!
I should want this!
Wait, what the fuck?
This is amazing!
I want this!
That's Pikachu...
That's the strongest Pikachu!
Oh my god!
I love this plushie!
I...
Okay, anyway...
Sorry, I got it.
I got a little off topic before.
But like, I feel like one of the main reasons why Pikachu got like...
the proportions of Pikachu changed was because the plushies just didn't look cute at all.
I thought they looked cute, but like, I guess when you compare to like, current Pikachu plushies versus like, Pikachu plushies now, um, like they're just like...
It's harder to make older Pikachu plushies because of the proportions.
It's not marketable enough because of the proportions.
It's like, it's like a version size for plushies, and like, it feels like it's harder to make.
But I used to own this.
I was trying to find this plushie.
I was trying to find this guy!
Um...
And...
And like, this is the one I...
I actually owned this plushie.
I used to own this as a little kid.
I remember because I like, loved this plushie so much.
Back then.
That's what I'm saying!
Digimon back then didn't have like, a lot of merch too.
It didn't have like, as much merch as Pokemon, which was really sad.
Um...
But yeah, anyway, um...
Anyway, if Terriomon existed back when Pikachu was like, the main contender, Terriomon would have won, like 100%.
Like, look at him!
He's so cute and his floppy ears!
And like, I honestly, like Terriomon would beat the shit out of Pikachu because he digivolves into something with guns.
I don't know.
For those who are not familiar, with Digimon, how they do uh, evolution compared to Pokemon is that the stronger they are, the more guns they get.
Like...
For those who...
Okay, Gargomon.
Yeah, he I forgot his evolution.
Um, oh yeah, and he has pants too.
I would admit Gargomon is not pretty, is not as pretty as Terriomon.
Um...
Anyway...
Like, I mean, he has guns for hands.
Like...
For those who...
Uh...
For those who like, uh, don't understand like Digimon digivolution, um, basically like, in order...
The stronger they get, um, the more guns they have.
Because I'm pretty sure like after Gargomon, he digivolves into like some guy with like missiles.
Oh yeah, there you go!
Mech... Okay, and then he turns into a mecha.
Rapidmon.
Um, this is like his his next evolution.
Or, uh, digivolution.
Uh, which is basically, uh...
Basically like missiles.
So, this is how they're... I know.
Okay, I would admit, like, for those who are like, oh, he's not as cute when they get older.
Um...
I could understand that.
But like...
But they have guns!
They have... They have guns and missiles!
Oh...
Look, they have missiles and guns.
That's all that matters.
Uh... Um, Envy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Teramon also has the Six Sister Unit.
Lopoma, who turns into an... Oh yeah, I know about Lopoma.
I don't like Lopoma because I don't like her color scheme.
I think like, um... I prefer I... I prefer Teramon over Lopoma because like, I feel like Teramon's color scheme is a lot cuter than Lopoma's color scheme.
Um...
So I... I personally prefer... I personally prefer Teramon more.
Also, I think Lopoma just has too, too many horns.
Because Lopoma has three horns and I'm like, that's too many horns.
Like, what the fuck are you doing with all those horns?
Like...
.
It turns into a...
Okay, but before it turns into a cool demon, it turns into a... Like, I don't want to say it but, like...
.
You know, before the...
Before the demon, um...
Digivolution, it turns into like... like a very ugly one.
And then it turns into a cooler...
.
Cooler, don't you...
Anyway, yeah, I'm talking about when... Okay, so before it turns into like the cooler demon, it turns into WendyGomon, which is like, in my opinion, like, not really... not that pretty.
Not that pretty.
But it's after that.
After that, he turns into a more handsome Digimon.
Alright, let me... Sorry, I got like so off topic.
I'm sorry.
I get like... When I get passionate about stuff, I tend to like... I get way too passionate.
Alright, the reason why I didn't have the game booted up is that the game starts playing a opening.
So, that's why I didn't have it opened.
Because I want you guys to watch the opening.
I didn't even watch the opening yet too?
All right, here we go.
Ooo, it's made in Unity!
Oh no.
It's copyrighted.
Oh no!
They're gonna get five cents off of this meme.
XD
Oh no, what are they gonna do?
Tell my company?
You mean the company that I own?
Oh, it crashed.
What the fuck?
Okay.
No, they got me!
They got me!
They got me, guys!
They didn't keep Bruce caught.
I got live caught.
No!
Oh no, I have to listen to the music again.
Oh no!
John Digimon!
Please!
They hit me live.
It would be funny if it crashes at that exact moment too.
It's a good song though.
Watch it crash again.
Alright, for those who don't know, sorry, I never explained the game.
But Digimon World Next Order is like the spiritual sequel.
I don't know if it's a sequel to the game.
I would say like spiritual sequel to the original Digimon World.
And Digimon World was like the very first PS1 game I've ever played.
But it was in Japanese.
So I didn't know what I was playing.
Like I didn't know what was going on.
But like I love the shit out of it.
Like it was like one of my favorite PS1 games.
Oh, is it sequel?
Sequel?
Full on sequel?
I feel like the only sequel part is that it's like the mechanics are like...
Are basically the same.
But like it doesn't build off of the original world from what I heard.
And they tend to not...
Nowadays they do JRPGs.
But back in the day they experimented a lot with Digimon games.
Digimon World!
Next Order!
They like... Digimon... Okay.
The reason why Pokemon is also more popular than Digimon is that they had a formula.
And they stuck it the entire...
Like...
The entire time they existed.
They found the most successful formula.
But Digimon...
Digimon had like the weirdest history.
Because it started off as like the male equivalent...
Male version of Tamagotchis.
Because Tamagotchis was really popular females.
And then they were like...
Well, we want males to...
We want guys...
Like little boys to play Tamagotchi like games too.
So they made Digimon.
And that's why they have more guns.
Because they're like...
What do boys like?
Oh yes.
Violence and guns.
Let's just add...
Let's add...
Let's give them guns!
Let's get these Tamagotchi pets guns!
That's what the little boys like.
That's sort of why the designs...
Because they're like...
Oh!
In Pokemon, people love Charmander.
So that's why the designs tend to have lots of guns and missiles and tanks and dragons and dinosaurs.
Because they're like...
What do the little boys like back then?
Oh yes.
Dinosaurs and guns.
So then they combined the two together and made Digimon.
Anyway...
After that, they were like...
What should the next series be when it comes to gaming?
And so they went with like...
Oh let's...
Let's give like...
I think...
Is Digimon World the first...
The next game they made for the console?
Next gen console?
So like then they went with Digimon World.
And that was also like...
Like you know...
It was like pet raising and fighting other Digimon.
But they die.
Okay.
I need...
I need to let you guys now know.
Digimon die in this game.
And they don't come back.
They're gone forever.
So...
I'm gonna make name all my Digimon after dragoons.
Anyway...
The stakes are...
Are very high here.
And...
And then Digimon World 2.
Oh yeah.
They made it a dungeon crawler.
So they went away from the original game.
And then they made it into a dungeon crawler.
I own Digimon World 2.
And I was like...
I thought it was gonna be like Digimon World 1.
And then so when I bought Digimon World 2.
I was very disappointed.
I was very...
I...
I remembered.
I remembered as a...
As a kid.
I was so excited.
It was the one...
Wait.
The character was like...
A Digimon with a sword in his mouth.
Right?
I don't remember.
They made a new Digimon just for Digimon World 2.
And then they made a new Digimon...
And I was so sad.
Because...
I was so sad.
Because I was like...
I love Digimon World 1.
Even though I didn't really know how to play it.
Because it was all in Japanese.
But I really enjoyed the game.
And...
But then so when I got Digimon World 2.
And it was in English.
I was so happy.
I was so...
Because...
Oh it wasn't the sword.
Was it not the sword Digimon?
That was 4?
Okay.
I need to look up Digimon World 2.
Now I'm like...
I'm like getting my Digimons confused.
I'm like...
Okay.
Because every Digimon World...
Oh no it wasn't Digimon 2.
It was 4.
Yeah.
4.
Digimon World 4 was so weird.
Because they had swords.
Wait.
Okay.
All right.
Let me.
Okay.
So every new Digimon World game was so weird.
It was so different.
It was...
Because I didn't know what to do.
And it was like...
So that's why I felt like...
Okay.
So this is the game name.
The first game I played, the next Digimon World game I played was 4.
But I went from Digimon World 1 to 4.
And I was like, what is this?
Like, why do they have swords?
I was so confused.
Like, I didn't know what was going on.
But every Digimon World is like different.
It's so different.
And I remember Digimon World 3.
I remember my dad bought me Digimon World 3.
And I had no idea how to play 3.
Because 3 was like an RPG.
And so I was like, okay.
And then I personally bought Digimon World 4.
Because I was like, oh my god, Digimon World 4.
Maybe this one will be similar.
And then Digimon World 4 was like...
You run around with swords killing other Digimon.
And I'm like, what?
I was like, where are the people?
So this is what like...
And I had no friends.
So, well, I had friends.
But they don't play video games.
So like, as like, you know...
Like all my...
I didn't really have friends that play video games.
So like this was Digimon World 4.
And it was so different.
It was so different from like the other Digimons I played.
And so like I was like literally the only girl in my class that played video games or consoles.
And like I never really hang out with the guys.
Other than like...
Oh, and my parents would not let me invite anybody over.
So like I don't think like the first time I've ever had people come over to my house was when I was like nine years old, I think.
Yeah, nine years old for a class project.
And like that was like literally the only time I've ever had like people over my house.
Because I was not allowed to have people over my house.
So like I had...
The first time was when I was nine.
It was a class project.
And then we played video games together.
And instead of doing our project...
I have to say...
Instead of doing our class project.
So I've always played video games by myself.
I've always played...
So I had no friends to play Digimon World 4 with me.
So I thought it was dog shit.
I was like, I don't like this.
I can't play this solo.
It's not a good solo game.
This game was definitely not meant to be played by me.
This game was meant to be played by myself.
Because I thought it was a bad game.
But then I saw people in my chat was like...
Oh, I had a great...
I had...
I had a great time playing with all my friends in Digimon World 4.
I was like, I didn't have friends to play this game with.
Is that why I thought it was dog shit?
Is that...
Is that why?
Anyway, as I was saying...
Um, Digimon did not know what its identity was...
when it came to video games.
Because every fucking iteration of a Digimon game is so different.
And now they're doing JRPGs.
Because CyberScoop did really, really well.
So like, I...
Okay, I was sad.
Because I thought Digimon Survive was supposed to be like a horror game.
Because like, I was like, oh, a Digimon horror game?
Oh my god.
I can't...
I'm so excited.
A Digi...
Oh my god, a Digimon horror game.
And then I found out it was like a visual novel.
Because like, the way they like, advertised Survive...
felt like it was...
Um...
Um, the way they advertised Survive at first...
It was like...
I felt like it was like a horror, more so like an action...
Not action, but like...
Um, you know what I mean when...
Like, not like a visual novel, but more of like gameplay-wise.
That it's not...
I didn't realize it was like a visual novel gameplay...
uh, game.
And I'm not like a huge fan of like visual novels...
in general.
Because that's a lot of reading.
That's a lot of reading!
I know like Cyber Snoop is like really good, but it's a JRPG and I'm not a JRPG player.
So like, it's not my type of genre.
Um, so like when they announced Survive, I was so excited because I was like, oh my god.
Like, that's like something they've never really done before.
Like a horror...
Like more so of a horror element.
Um, so I was like super hyped up and then I found out it was a visual novel and then I didn't touch it.
So...
I was just like...
Oh, it's...
It's a visual novel.
Guess...
Guess I...
Guess I won't be touching that game anymore.
Because I can't...
I also heard they released a horror anime based off of Digimon as well.
Which was...
I thought it was really interesting.
Um, they...
I...
That's why like in the West, it was...
Digimon was not as popular.
Um...
It was not as popular as it is versus Pokemon.
Just because like they didn't establish an identity early on in Pokemon when they had like such a dominant force in the West in NA.
That like, uh...
They just like took over.
They literally...
Um...
They literally got...
Like it literally got taken over.
That was just too late.
Like they had such a stronghold in the market when it comes to like, you know, uh...
A little like...
Like monster companions.
That was so hard for Digimon to like, um...
Expand more after that.
But I still like Digimon more than Pokemon because I personally think that...
Their...
The anime and the designs are a lot better than Pokemon.
Even like the more recent designs.
I feel like Digimon is much more creative when it comes to like the more recent iterations.
I do not...
Personally do not like the newer designs of Pokemon.
And like I felt like the newer designs for Pokemon is more so markability in terms of merch.
Than like what actually looking good to me.
I don't know.
This is my personal opinion.
But I feel like...
Um...
It's...
The designs are not as good as it once was.
Because I feel like the more recent ones...
The...
It's so simple.
Like not simple.
But there's just something...
Off of it.
About it for me.
Like...
It's just...
There's something...
Off.
About the newer Pokemon designs.
Um...
And...
And so like...
That's why...
Like even the starters too.
I'm not like a...
I don't really like the newer starters designs lately.
Um...
But I feel like Digimon designs...
In my opinion the newer designs...
I do like it a lot more.
Um...
Because they're not afraid to do like more...
Uh...
Complicated stuff when it...
Complicated more memorable stuff.
Versus like...
Uh...
Pokemon.
Um...
Because like...
Some of the designs that Digimon does...
Is like...
What the f...
How do you make that...
Like a marketable plushie?
Like...
It looks cool!
But like...
How do you make that like a fucking plushie?
Like...
Yeah...
Digimon is like...
More experimental...
When it comes to their designs.
I...
Heavily agree.
Um...
So...
I just realized...
I don't want to talk too much to you guys...
But I was like...
So...
Sorry...
I was like...
I'm sorry...
Sorry...
I love...
I love Digimon!
Easy for those who just want...
Not for...
For those familiar with the world.
I'll do easy.
Um...
If I do normal...
Guys...
You can't be like...
No, Doki.
Do normal.
Don't be a pussy!
Let's see!
If I do normal, you guys will die in like less than a day.
So, do you guys want to live and survive and live out your life until you're elderly?
Or do you want to die the moment you like poop?
I am ready to die.
Oh!
The girl's cute!
Oi, Shiki is so much cuter than Takuto.
I think that's his name.
Oh!
I don't like the blue thing coming out of his head.
Like, I know that's his hair, but I'm not a huge fan of that.
I think Shiki's cute.
Please enter the name.
Ooh, me.
Doki.
The cuter Doki.
Oh!
Okay, cute.
Okay, is this eight?
One, two, three, four, five...
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Okay.
Cuter Doki.
Cute Doki.
There you go.
That's eight.
We'll die for the content.
Oh, there's DigiDevice.
Oh my god, I got chosen!
I got ch-ch-ch-chosen!
I
got ch-ch-ch-ch-chosen!
I mean, technically it is an isekai, but like, I basically got transported into the digi world.
The digi-digital world.
We're gonna become digital champions.
Ooh!
Hm.
There's something over there.
The chat died?
How the fuck did you guys die?
Like, what happened?
How did you guys die?
Okay, give me a sec, let me fix it.
I don't- I don't know.
I actually don't know why it does that.
I don't know if it's like the chat CSS, or if it's just something to do with the new OBS.
Don't worry, I fixed you guys.
Okay, the volume is low.
You know what's funny?
It's not letting me go to my settings.
Can I- Oh, I cannot- Guys, I literally cannot go to the settings here.
They locked me in!
They locked me in here!
Yeah, I was gonna say, it's not really an isekai.
Because the digital world is part of this world.
Um, it's just the digital world.
We're literally in your computers.
Oh no, he's evil.
Machine dream on.
Can I pet it?
He's so cool!
What the fuck is that guy?
Oh my god!
Wait, that wasn't you two?
Oh yeah, by the way, they can talk.
For those who are not familiar with Digimon, they can talk to us.
It's like a grown man in this dog.
What is it?
You've always given us commands in battle.
Oh, they're my Digimon!
You seem really confused, all of us.
It can't be helped.
We'll back you up.
He's got that dog in him.
You've gotta be kidding me.
You're not supposed to forget us.
You're partners.
Alright, Digimon battles.
In pursuit of victory, your partner Digimon will choose and attack targets of their own accord.
However, teamers can use orders to command them more directly.
Open ordering for partner L.
I had two?
I did multitask?
Multitask?
Okay, I can do this.
Left stick, order.
So you can open the ring...
Okay, I'm glad I had coffee.
How long you have left to give it before the ring closes?
The timer stopped when she was ordered, but only for 5 seconds.
The ring closes the timer when she was ordered, and you'll have to wait 5 seconds to open it again.
Try it out!
Okay.
Order WarGreymon to use the Mach Jab.
RB and tilt left then press A.
Okay, I need to use the Jab.
There they are.
Umm... Mach Jab.
Alright.
Do your thing!
Oh, he did it!
Okay, and then next try use Agitation.
MetalGurumon.
Okay.
I can do this.
Alright, Metal...
Where's Metal?
Where is it?
Oh... No!
I'm sorry MetalGurumon!
Oh, agitated.
It was right here?
Okay, nice.
We'll let him automatically recover HP for a period of time.
There are various types of agitation time used as a Digimon.
Um, and hair abilities.
He added more order power.
For stronger order power, you need...
Okay, for stronger orders, you need more order power.
So you'll require your partners to build more order powers.
Press A buttons to support WarGreymon until you've gathered 150.
When a partner attack has hit and after taking damage, that's your chance!
After using support, you will need to wait a bit before using it again.
Okay, is he doing it?
Is he doing it?
Yeah!
Support!
Go!
I'm cheating them on!
You're getting the hang of it, I am!
I don't know who I am!
Does it look like I know what I'm doing, guys?
Bam!
Woo!
Oh my god, he's doing the thing!
It's the terror force!
I remember that in the anime!
I'm beginning to believe.
I'm so strong!
No good?
No.
I have to keep going.
I've finally met my tamer.
This is where I'm a goner?
I finally met you!
Guys, you can't give up!
You finally met me, guys!
Gotta keep going!
I see.
We may be defeated here.
But we won't let that happen to you!
Ha!
It happened!
Too cute, Doki!
Do it for Doki!
Oh my god, we're bonding!
Yeah!
You don't wanna be losers?
You're winners!
Dragons, you're winners!
You gotta keep going!
Alright.
LB to open for both.
Normally, the icon here is for Digifuse skills.
In certain circumstances, EXE will be available.
At the same time, and tilt then press A.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, let me out of the ring of destruction.
Okay.
Uh...
Alright, what's this?
Extra cross evolution?
Am I gonna digivolve?
Are we fusing?
The PGM!
Oh!
Uh!
The PGM!
Digimon!
The OGs!
God!
Thank you, Super Chat!
The...
Thank you, Gothamette!
Oh my god, you're fusing!
What are you gonna become?
Oh!
Oh that guy!
I forgot his name.
Is it Omegamon?
Omegamon!
His arm... oh shit!
He gets a sword and gun?
Success!
With EXE, your partner Digimon will fuse into extra powerful forms.
After the battle is over, your Digimon will separate again.
Guys, we can't fall in love with this Digimon because he's gonna die.
That's the whole point of this game.
Wait, is he dead?
Wait, did he die?
No, you can't die!
What?!
We lost?!
We need to be sleepy!
We must defend our partner!
I love how the cutscene audio is so quiet compared to the game.
I can't believe it!
Right after they Digi-fused, they fucking just died like that?!
Wait, they won!
Then what was the point of fusing?
What was the point of fusing?
What was the point of fusing if like... they're just better separately?
Some people are just not meant to be together.
Oh yeah, and then when they die, they just devolve.
So now they're a baby.
Yay!
What about you, Dragoons?
Um...
Are you... how old are you guys?
Are you guys gonna die of old age soon?
Oh.
Oh, I guess...
I guess they're dead?
Just... just one thing.
Peace.
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh no, you guys are fine!
It seems like it.
Hmm?
A human?
A machine Draymond disappears and a human appears.
Fascinating!
Oh, it's him!
It's Gigi-mon!
This person was in...
This guy was in the first Digimon World game.
You defeated that machine Draymond.
That must be what destabilized the other dimension.
Hmm.
These must be your partners.
Yeah!
Dragoon 1 and Dragoon 2.
That's an odd relationship.
Okay, wait, wait.
What?
I can't have two Digimons?
Like...
If Pokemon can have six, I can have two!
They did everything they could to defend you.
Don't make it weird.
I'm not making it weird!
He's making it weird!
I'm gonna have three Digimons too!
That little guy right there is gonna join the squad!
Why did Mom let you have two Digimons?
No need to look so depressed.
They were partner Digimon.
So it is possible to revive them with a Digi-egg.
I have preserved them.
Wait, they just died.
They have them in external storage.
Wait, did they actually die?
Oh shit!
07, that was fast.
Goodbye Dragoon 1 and Dragoon 2.
So, hold your partner in your heart.
Goodbye Dragoon 1 and 2.
That was so fast.
Wait, isn't this Terriormon?
Wait, which one is...
Okay, I want Gatomon.
I'm trying to remember.
I'm trying to remember which one was which.
Digivolution details.
Tsunomon.
Okay.
Which one was this?
Tokomon.
Rare in training.
It has hands and feet.
It's cute but it has...
Oh, this one is the...
It's the triangle...
It's the yellow cat, right?
Okay, but like which one...
Which one...
This one is Gatomon.
Which one is this one?
I don't remember this one.
Gummymon?
That grew from Bright and Cheerful.
It has a high horn.
Which one was this one?
Is that Terriormon?
That's Terrier?
That's Terriormon?
I'm gonna get Terriormon.
Oh my god, this is so difficult.
I don't know if I should get...
Terriormon or Gatomon.
I'm gonna get Terriormon.
I like Terriormon more.
This is Lopo.
I know this is Lopomon.
And this is...
I'm gonna get...
Oh, it's so difficult.
Okay, when Terriormon dies, I'm gonna get Gatomon later.
Yay!
Dragon 3 and 4, let's go.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Zerimon!
Oh, I get two.
I can get Gatomon and Terriormon.
Oh my god.
Dragon 3.
No!
That's okay.
Dragoon 3.
What are more words?
I can't do...
That's...
How would you know it's one or two more?
Zerimon is not even a real word!
Dragonmon!
Dragoon 2mon!
Nothing!
Nothing...
This is good?
DRAG MON 3 GUN MON 3 Okay.
Oh my god!
It's not fair!
You may- Oh now I can't even enter 8 letters.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6...
That's 7!
What?!
Okay.
DRAG MON 3 What do you mean?!
Wait.
I didn't name him!
I didn't!
Did I- What?
What happened?!
Wait, what happened?!
Did I- Wait!
I didn't name him!
Why did I name him?!
Nooooo!
Now he's just default man!
You went bad.
Nooooo!
Okay, we're gonna grab our Gato Mon 2.
Oh, I can rename him later?
Thank god.
Wait, I can't believe GUN is a bad word.
Did he-
Oh, you gave me a book- Oh, I'm sorry.
They get like- Like 200,000- Oh, I'm sorry.
That is more than 8 letters!
That- This is more than 8 letters!
This is not fair!
That's like 50!
Like, why can you give me a book that's like 50?!
Gato Mon!
50 letters!
And I'm restricted to 8!
I can't believe it!
Okay, drag mon...
Um...
Drag mon 4.
You may enter- That's not fair!
Drag...
Oh, we used Roman numerals!
Guys, what's in the Roman numeral for 4?
Again.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven...
What's the Roman numeral?
IV, okay.
God damn it!
Okay.
Dra- Dra-mon IV.
Okay, there you go.
Oh my god, that's our way!
That's how we're gonna do this!
This is a tremendous success!
Roman numerals!
Then their rebirths will be complete.
We can't go in the bad way!
Just remember, as their tamer, you have a duty to care for them.
Okay.
Hmm...
You don't seem to understand what's what.
I am just as in the dark as you.
I wonder what is going on.
Why don't we go to my house and you can tell me your story.
Okay.
Looks like Tokomon is still unconscious.
Wait, is Tokomon not gonna be my Digimon?
I thought I can- I can't have three?
So you were sucked in by the Digivice and unluckily fell into the dimension I created.
Wait, you're gone?
And then your partners in the Digivice defeated Machine Draymond for me.
I see.
Coincidence has been our friend today.
I owe you my thanks.
Actually, this world is at a crisis point.
As you can see, the city we are in, Floatia, is in disarray.
What's happening in Floatia?
I don't know.
It's because of the Machine Draymond.
Yeah, him!
I made him small now.
He started attacking us for no reason and did a lot of damage to the city.
Oh, like Kanya's Goon?
He just Kanya's Nier Merl?
Oh, okay.
I know what to name our Digimon now.
It appeared from nowhere and caused massive damage and then disappeared.
We were at our wits' end.
I mobilized my knowledge and technology to build a trap in order to capture the Machine Draymond.
I thought that when it appeared, I could transport it to another dimension and imprison it.
The plan worked.
In fact, the plan went even better than expected.
Thanks to you, we were able to defeat that Machine Draymond.
But that doesn't mean the danger has entirely passed.
The phenomenon of a Machine Draymond getting violent and then disappearing has occurred several times in many areas.
It would be hard to believe that it is just one lone Mega Digimon doing all this damage.
So there's more of them that we have to stop.
We were able to survive this time because of your valiant efforts.
Unfortunately, we don't know from where and how the Machine Draymond are appearing.
It seems hopeless.
But if we just had a clue, maybe we could do something.
If only we had a clue.
Take away all the Digimon that like digivolve into Machine Draymond and teach them about the power of good.
It's just that easy.
Because they come from a specific line of Digimon.
And all we have to do is make sure they don't go evil.
What?
This Tokomon was the Machine Draymond?
It can't be.
No.
But I am sensing a strange data wave coming from this Tokomon.
That's every evil Machine Digimon.
Then we'll get all the Machine Digimon!
What should we make of this?
A Tokomon living in this city that digivolved into a Machine Draymond?
I've never heard of such a Digi... Get all the Tokomon together and teach them the power of good.
There's something here in the cloud memory.
But why did this Tokomon digivolve into Machine Draymond?
Just delete the code.
Or we just delete the code.
Or at least an alternate form of Machine Draymond.
Get the code and just delete the line.
That's all we need to do.
We won't be able to figure it out with just this small amount of information from this Tokomon.
But it looks like we finally have a chance to actually do something about this threat.
We need to act.
I have something to ask of you.
Just erase them.
It's like they never existed in the code.
We want to return you back to the world you came from as soon as possible.
But we can't leave this city in the state it's in.
To get the city back to the way it was, will you help bring back the residents that fled from the Machine Draymond attacks?
Why don't you do it yourself?
Yeah, old man.
I would do it myself, but there are too many children in the city.
I can't leave them alone.
I can babysit the kids.
So, go out with your partners and look for the residents who fled the city.
But like, why is he allowed to just like...
I will look into this small amount of strange data.
Why is he allowed to stay here?
We have collected more information about the people outside the city than me.
I just got here.
He's old.
He's not old.
It's just what he looks like.
You can't grow old in Digimon.
You just die.
That's why I first intend to make a detection device.
That's literally what he looks like.
He's not a real person.
He's a Digimon.
He was born in the city.
I'm programmed to look like this.
So please check your Digi-vice.
He was born in...
So then, I'm counting on you.
He's literally an old, mad Digimon.
Okay, it's not much, but all of us got these items for you.
Oh, thank you, Kuromon!
Oh my god, I got Portable Toilet!
Okay, guys.
For those who are like, why do you have a portable toilet?
If you don't poop, you're actually... you die.
You get... you turn like ugly, apparently.
If you don't poop, you turn ugly in your Digivolution.
So I gotta make sure you like...
I gotta... I gotta make sure you use the bathroom.
How do I...
How do I like...
Oh, there we go.
It's Y.
Okay, um...
Alright, we gotta bring... Oh my god, he yapped a lot.
Okay, we gotta bring stuff down.
Okay, uh... voice...
We bring down voice a little bit.
And then, we bring down music a little bit, too.
Alright.
And then, we'll bring this down as well.
Alright, that should be good.
Alright.
I wanna rename you.
How do I rename... Oh, I got Digi-mail!
Bring Digimon to town.
Alright, we gotta look at the nine planes.
Okay.
Uh... partner.
Um... how do I change your name?
Zerriermon.
Uh... how do I change your name, guys?
I'm gonna rename you.
I wanna rename you guys.
How do I do it?
I don't want you guys to be cut.
Oh, I could...
Uh... Bakamon?
That's not Bakamon.
That's Gigi-mon.
Who are you?
Punimon.
Who do you wanna talk about?
I can tell you all you need to know about battle.
Okay, not that.
Uh...
You're not Bakamon.
You're Kodomon.
Oh, I have a chest.
Who are you?
That's Poyomon.
Dimensional boxes?
What the fuck is that?
Alright.
Presents.
Oh, do I get presents?
Omega, Alt...
Digivolution?
Oh!
What the fuck did I receive?
Battle Rankings?
Okay, we're not fighting.
Oh, that's PvP.
Oh, I have new mail!
Daily quest.
Gather three quick fruits.
Oh, I get 3000.
Oh my gosh, there's quests and everything?
The longer I wait, the...
Oh, that's you guys!
The 4HC now is the one Gigi-mon and the rest of us have work to rebuild.
But you're all children!
How are you rebuilding?
Oh, Kyudoki, hold on.
Yeah?
I show you around Felicia and teach you all sorts of things.
But you're a child!
How are you teaching me?
You're literally a child!
Okay.
Yeah, I need a tour guide anyway.
They're actually all kids!
Who let these kids work here?
Why are you letting children run the city?
Is this the children town?
The infamous town for kids?
That's shut down?
The name is Tainmon.
Why do you think it was super chat?
Thank you.
There isn't a single game that wouldn't be improved with a poop mechanic.
Not a single one.
How do you get me from this?
Why?
What's so weird about that?
Who let the kids run the city?
Kidnation!
Oh my god, it's kidnation all over again!
If not enough, go get some mushrooms or something.
When your partners are hungry, give them some meat.
You picked up.
Oh, there's the portable potty.
And you know what comes up?
That's why we have a bathroom here.
As for a bathroom break, you'd better hurry on over here!
Next to that is the training hall.
The training hall is a very important facility.
They'll explain everything when you go inside.
Okay, yeah, you guys gotta train too.
It's to train your partner Digimon.
For now, I'll give you a real rough rundown.
Touch this to do some training.
The training input will pop up.
Set and confirm what gear you want to partner.
Once time takes a single hour, it makes the Digimon tired.
Keep an eye on the fatigue.
In the etude, they could get sick or their life could diminish if that happens.
Let them rest on this bed.
Oh, he's so cute!
Talk to Chichimon when it's time to rest.
When the sleep sign appears, let them sleep in care mode.
Oh my god, look at him!
He's so cute!
Alright.
If there's anything you don't get after that, ask Tsunomon and Mutimon about it.
They're all children!
They're actually all just...
Cause like, okay, by the way, these aren't even supposed to be children, cause these are babies.
Oh no, these are babies, and then these guys are like adolescents or something.
They're like toddlers.
Yeah, these are like I was just born, and these are like babies.
So like, I'm literally asking babies on what to do.
They're rookie.
You want to see this white machine here.
When you train, power will build up.
When the power fills up, you can improve that gear.
But there's no Digimon in the city that can do improvements yet.
I'm a master at training.
Go on, ask me.
You're a child!
Would you...
You're not a master of anything!
You're literally a child!
Training is focused more around adjusting Digivolution-related skills, but another important part is food effects.
Food items can be divided into eight types.
Um, no thank you.
I don't really want to know.
Alright, let's start training one of you guys.
Let's train.
You can train your party positions with the left and right stick.
Stats on both sides around the circle of the set gear will increase a little.
For example, if strength is set, then stats and speed will also increase a little.
Bonuses are shown on both sides.
If you have a bonus, the stat will increase more.
Confirm with A.
Okay.
Uhhh...
I want you guys to be strong.
I want you guys to be...
You're not.
You don't need wisdom.
Alright, go.
Play the role... Yo.
Press A to stop spinning.
Your win was indicated.
Then it... time it well and you may get... Oh!
Wait, which one is it?
This.
Alright.
Yay!
Each time a Digimon train, fatigue increases.
They are in danger when their fatigue level is over 50%.
Give them rest or let them sleep.
Oh, it doesn't matter which one you hit.
Any icon?
Oh, okay.
You guys are fine.
Are you guys hungry?
How do I get you guys out of here?
I'm going to go to the other side.
Oh no.
After training 2, I can definitely...
After training 2, I can definitely dive into...
something.
I'm going out now.
I'll think it over.
Alright, I guess you guys have to keep training.
Oh, you guys are hungry?
Um...
I'm sorry.
I...
Be serious!
Sorry.
They won't let me give you guys food.
So...
Oh, I can feed them here?
Items.
Where is it?
Meat?
How do I feed you guys?
I'm just going to let you starve.
Am I?
Oh, okay.
Hey guys!
I have food!
I would never let you guys starve.
But...
A popular mushroom with digital sports.
I'm just going to give you guys mushrooms.
Meat is so hard to get.
So you guys are going to get mushrooms.
Alright.
Wait down by...
Did I feed both of you guys?
Oh, I did!
Alright.
You're not hungry anymore, right?
You're still hungry?
Oh, I didn't feed you!
Sorry.
Sorry, I don't need...
You can tell which one is my favorite.
Come on!
Eat up!
Here you go.
Now!
Alright, there you go.
Now you guys are fat.
Okay.
Back to training you go.
More strength.
Be strong!
Yay!
Alright.
Now you're stronger!
Are you digivolving?
You're digivolving!
What are you?
Now you're a slime!
Now you're Gummymon!
Where's the other one?
Oh, there you go.
You're going to be Cat now!
This guy digivolved too!
Naruman!
Oh my god!
Please, no.
You're not going to be smart.
I can't have Dragoons for a long time.
You're smarter than me.
Alright.
Alright, now we leave.
Are you going out?
I think you better at least...
Are you not Rookie?
Wait, are you...
Is this not Rookie?
Are we still in Toddler form?
Is this still...
Is this not Rookie?
They aren't a Rookie yet?
Oh, this is Toddler!
Okay.
Back to strength, guys.
Back to...
More strength!
Wait, is this like revival?
It's MP.
That's magic, right?
Now it's Baby too.
Alright, back to...
Okay, back you go.
There you go.
Yay!
It's not 50% yet, so I can keep going.
Alright, guys.
You're still going to be training.
Alright, let's do it!
You're still... More strength!
More strength!
It's...
Un-ga-pung-a-time!
No!
I missed it!
Oh, now you're...
Who said you can be hungry?
Alright, here we go.
You guys need to poop yet?
No, you don't have poop meters.
You're still fine.
Here you go.
You're so...
Me-me!
Little ones.
Alright, now they're completely full.
Okay.
Wait, do you need poop?
What is that?
Where are those icons?
Are you guys okay?
Are you...
My tummy hurt!
Alright, let's see.
Um...
Wait, I can check the...
Digivolution line.
Uh...
Let's see.
Where is it?
Partner...
History...
No, it's more so here.
Oh, no!
Wait, I can make you...
Renamod?
Oh, no!
Oh, no.
You're not gonna turn...
No!
That's not fair!
Why do you have to be smart?
You're too dumb to be a cat!
It's not fair!
Why are you too dumb to be a cat!
I need to turn things down.
I'm going to turn it down by another 10.
And then music by another 7.
There we go.
I can't believe it!
Okay, what I can't believe is that you turn into a puppy and then into a cat.
That one was what I can't believe too either.
I can't believe it!
Renamon's a rookie?
Renamon should not be a rookie, not going to lie.
Renamon is like a woman.
You guys know damn well.
Renamon is not like a rookie.
Not right.
Okay, no, you got to be smart!
Fuck yeah, I'm going with Renamon.
I'm going to have woman.
All right, Teramon.
No!
You don't, you're not even smart!
Teramon, you need defense?
Oh my God.
Who the fuck wants...
Haguruman.
No, none of them is strength.
Respect for Gaomon.
Okay, we need...
We need...
Um...
We need defense and speed.
Okay, defense, speed.
What about you?
We need...
Uh...
Oh, we don't even have like the conditions for Renamon.
Renamon needs fucking magic.
You don't even...
You don't even love it yet.
Okay, we got a...
All right, we're just going to go with cat.
Uh...
Hahaha.
Renamon is a woman.
I screamed to the police officer.
Thank you for the super chat, Razza.
Thank you.
Renamon should not be a rookie Digimon.
How is Renamon a rookie?
Renamon fucking beats the shit out of like all the other Digimon.
She's so tall.
She's so fucking tall.
Okay.
Wisdom and speed.
Goddamn, I have to give you guys books now.
Okay.
All right, you two rest for now.
Wait, can I not make you guys rest?
How do I make you guys rest?
Are you guys not resting yet?
All right, rest.
You guys not resting?
Yes, rest.
Yeah.
If rookie, why tall?
Uh, Scrooge, thank you for the one gift this year.
Thank you.
That's so true.
Why are they tall?
Okay, fuck.
I now need to figure out what your lines are.
Figure out your evolution line.
All right.
Okay, you are going to become Terimon.
I need stat and speed.
Okay, stat and speed.
And then I have to buy you...
I need to buy you a book.
All right, here we go.
Nice.
Stat.
Okay, wisdom.
You went up, wisdom.
Now you got a poop?
God damn it.
Get over here.
We're taking you to the party.
They need a poop.
I can't stop them from that.
Okay.
There aren't anything around here yet, but you have a bunch more Digimon.
Come here, call them or bring them.
Then you can build facility and get to work.
It all depends on the effort you put in.
Oh, there's a bathroom in the gym?
I don't know.
I didn't know that.
This exit takes you out of the city.
Outside there are Digimon that will attack you.
If you play it right, you can avoid battles entirely.
If things get dicey, head back to the city.
Or you can open a Digi-vice by pressing Y.
You can check...
As well as Digi-mails sent to you there.
What the fuck happened?
Why are these kids so knowledgeable?
That's the end of my explanation.
Thank you for listening.
Alright.
They seem satisfied.
We are in our new strength.
Alright.
You guys did great, Dragoons.
Who is a good Dragoon?
Bon up!
Yay!
Alright.
Go use the potty now.
Go poop.
Go.
Oh, we can't see.
What?
There's literally a door.
Like, I'm not going to watch it.
I can't even see.
Oh, only one of you needs to poop?
Alright, get over here.
What do you want me to see?
Alright, we gotta make sure you're a rookie.
Alright, speed... wisdom.
Are they... are they smart enough yet?
Alright, here we go.
Did they poop together?
Alright, 76... 94.
Okay, how much did you guys need?
76, 94?
Oh my... okay.
Oh, we got 8!
Okay, 80.
Now you just need MP.
Alright, we need... oh wait, no.
That's not what we need.
We need more stats.
Fuck!
Okay, we need 150.
I'm not turning you into Toy Agumon!
You're not gonna be Agumon under this roof!
I don't care!
I don't care if this is your calling!
You're never gonna be Agumon under this house!
Alright, let's see.
We still need to be smarter.
You're not gonna be Agumon!
If you live under this roof, I will never let you be a dinosaur!
I need to buy you guys more books.
Over here!
Why?
But, Donkey, I wanna be a dinosaur!
Dinosaur!
You don't like this item?!
Stop it!
You think you can decide what you wanna eat?!
Time to eat!
That's right, now eat this mushroom!
Good.
Alright, now you're not hungry anymore.
There you go.
Keep this tire bomb.
Alright.
Oh, no bonus.
Pooping with homies is a bonding experience.
You wouldn't get it!
Thank you for the super chat, Kaz!
Thank you, thank you!
Are you guys... are you guys there yet?
Alright, 94.
Wisdom, 22.
The dinosaurs are closer to dragons than cats, Donkey!
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Alright, are you guys tired?
How are you guys tired already?!
How are you guys tired?!
What's your tired meter?
Oh my god, you guys are tired.
I should take you to bed.
Alright.
Rest.
Wait, we're still okay.
Wait, I don't know if I should like put you guys...
Uh, Donkey, don't make us read.
Alright.
Now rest.
It's like a bear.
You ate!
You ate the mushroom in the end!
Wait, what?
Are you guys digifoaming?
No.
No!
I told you!
You cannot turn into Aquaman!
No!
What am I gonna do with two Aquamans?!
What?!
What am I...
What am I gonna do with two Aquamans?!
Let's go!
This is who I am, mother!
Oh my god!
What am I gonna do?!
You fucking just deceived me!
I wanna tear your mind!
And...
And Gato's mind!
What am I fucking gonna do with Legos?!
Wait!
Somebody's just gonna take you apart!
Accept us!
Why did you make us ugly?
Ally, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh my god!
Damn, that Lego looks...
That Lego is you!
What am I gonna do with this?!
I don't even know what you can digivolve!
Why you did this to us?!
I want you to be a cat!
Oh... I guess I leave now!
Wait!
They seem satisfied with their new strength from training!
Don't worry, you'll die soon so I can restart!
I hope perfect this formula.
I hope perfect...
Alright.
What do I even get?
A fucking wizard mod?
You just turned into a person?
I don't want you to be Hyaga mod!
He's so... he looks so ugly!
Alright.
What the fuck do I do with you two?
What?
Alright.
I wanna make the city even more wonderful.
The city.
Is it a village city?
This is a city.
Where do I... where is the guy that...
It appears sometimes when you pick up materials.
It's hard to get...
Let's go.
We get to be wizards.
Well, I guess we leave the city now.
Alright.
Oh, there's Patamon!
Beat him up!
From here on, Digimon will appear to attack you as enemies.
Enemy Digimon react when you approach them.
They will chase you and...
Tetsuon will start a battle.
A Digimon that doesn't react may be one that comes to the city.
Talk to them with A or get closer.
Trigger an event.
Is that hostile?
Oh my god, there he is.
I hope...
Oh my god, it better be an enemy.
It's time.
Are you friendly or not?
No!
He's friendly!
Are you one of those humans?
Oh, I see you're controlling Machine Dreammon.
How dare you mess with Flutia.
I'll...
Oh, yes!
Yes!
It's time to teach Patamon a lesson!
Time to teach this giant thumb a lesson!
I think I was like, he's friendly.
Y'all chill.
He is definitely not friendly.
Use those claws!
Oh, you were not clo... You have to be close enough?
Beat him up!
Yeah, that's right.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
Now you got it.
I figured it out.
That's right.
Did you learn your lesson?
It doesn't really hurt.
It doesn't hurt.
Let's go back to town.
GGmon's waiting.
Potato down.
You know GGmon?
Don't tell me you're not a bad guy.
Is that right?
My bad.
I got ahead of myself.
I've never seen a human before, you see?
Right then, I'm going back to Flutia.
Give me a holler if you see me out there.
Wait, what does Patamon get me?
Patamon joined the city.
Please be proud of us.
The wild Digimon decided to join.
Now let's find some partner Digimon and bring them back.
Also, the Digimon mark appeared in the lower right corner.
A notice was displayed whatever DigiMail is delivered.
Okay, I know that.
What new DigiMail did I get?
I got mail.
Is your DigiMonsters going well?
I picked up lots of information about Digimon.
And asked the Botamon in my house to pass it on to you.
If you need any help, go talk to him.
Wait, wasn't he the one that was like... that can change names?
Does Botamon let me change names?
I don't remember... you guys said that one of them lets me change names.
I don't remember which one.
Oh, it's Bakumon?
Bukamon?
Oh, it's the fish one.
I have good news?
Yeah, I fucking beat him up to come back home.
The city prosperity is now won.
There's still a long way to go.
It's the fish one.
Okay.
Wait, stop looking at me like that.
Oh my god, you're so fucking ugly.
Oh, wait.
Like... look at you.
Don't be... at least... you know what?
Like... you're okay.
Compared to this guy over here.
How do you sleep?
I don't understand.
You sleep?
Let me sleep.
Okay, there you go.
Sleep on the floor.
Mom, please don't hate us.
No, I'm not talking about you.
You look fine.
You're... you know, you're just Agumon.
But like, wait.
You... you're a...
You have a face that even a mother couldn't love.
And I'm the mother.
But you, you're great, sweetie.
You look amazing.
It's food time.
Alright, are you guys satisfied?
You're still hungry?
Freaky Lego mom.
That's all you got.
Okay.
I wanted a fucking cat.
We can do something with you.
I wanted a cat.
Okay, let's...
Oh yeah, we can get another more meat.
The next day.
Here's the meat.
Five?!
You gave me ten yesterday.
Hey!
Are you... Oh, Bakumon!
Alright, we gotta change your name.
Yeah, uh, I wanna change Toy Agumon.
Okay, Toy Agumon.
Okay, Goon...
Uh, Goon 3.
There we go.
2, 4, 5, 6, 7... Yeah, there we go.
Goon 3.
Wait, what?
I can't do that?
Goon is actually a name you can't say!
3-mon... Okay, there we go.
Oh my god.
3... D-Drumon.
Goon is actually a fan.
Alright.
Let's see, Patamon.
No Gooning here.
Leave Duplamon alone.
Thank you for the super chat, fans.
I thank you, thank you.
And store... I don't need to store anything.
Alright, get over here.
No Goons allowed.
Get over here.
I have to make do with what I have.
Alright, we got five...
We gotta... We got five more Digimon.
Is there a thing here?
Where?
Where's the thing?
Here?
We can't get down here yet.
What's this thing are you guys talking about?
Alright, let's grab some mushrooms though.
You guys need more food.
Yay!
The game hates us?
No, no, I don't hate you!
I don't hate you, D-Drumon4!
It's you and I against the world.
Be strong for your mother.
Holy shit, this guy's huge!
Wait, he's level 6!
Are we strong enough?
Well, it's time to find out.
If you guys die, I can always...
uh, restart.
You guys do it!
Go, go, go!
Oh, you're alive!
Oh, you're...
Oh shit, you're alive!
Okay...
You can't be mad at me!
You literally died!
I just broke apart.
You can't be mad at me!
You lied!
You literally are mad that you ran away, but you literally almost died in front of me!
I literally ran away so you guys can live!
You know what, you didn't...
I was... I was supposed to know he was so much stronger!
Alright.
Let's collect some materials.
Mom, you only care for brother.
Oh,
okay.
It was like three times our size.
It was a level 6 champion.
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry that you're too weak!
If you were a cat, you would have won the fight.
Anyway...
The further you go, the stronger your enemies become.
You must build the strength of your partners.
For now, let's go to the 9 planes and get used to living with your partner Digimon.
Oh, there's another guy!
You guys can take him on, right?
I'll take this opportunity to explain more.
I filled up your partners.
Let's do this battle to learn.
Oh, I should have went left instead of right.
Use the tactics methods to flee or change targets using items.
Time will be paused when the box is opened.
You can select items by moving up and down.
Okay.
Item to both partners.
Press L or R to change focus and use items individually.
LB or RB to change focus and use items individually.
Toss the right items to partners depending on the situation and give yourself a big advantage.
Press X to open the tactics menu.
Time will be paused when this is opened.
Here you can confirm who is targeting who or abandon and flee the fight.
If you choose to flee, you will be returned to the entrance of the sub arena.
Press L, B, or RB to individual commands.
The top commands indicate automatic MP usage in battle and the bottom command determines the target enemy.
Switch these depending on the situation and dominate in battle.
Okay.
You guys will be fine, right?
Yeah!
You guys just do that thing.
Now fight!
Fight!
See, you're fine.
See, it's like nothing bad happened.
See, they're level one!
Wow!
It's like, you know, you should have been fighting Digimon of your own level.
You guys did it!
Yay!
Good thing you guys fought Digimon of your own level, guys!
It's a good thing!
Now realize you guys were level one this entire time.
Um...
Guys, why didn't you tell me you were level one?
No...
Oh shit, you need a poop.
Okay.
Okay, um, we're gonna head home.
We're gonna head home.
Guys, no, no, no!
Hold in your poops, guys!
Hold it in!
Guys, please!
The city is like right beside us!
There's a toilet nearby?
Wait, where's the toilet?
Where's the toilet near us?
There's a potty potty?
Oh, there it is!
I see it!
It's over the bridge!
Guys, hold your poop!
Guys, there's a bathroom over the bridge!
No!
I'm not wasting my potty potty!
I literally have two!
Hold it in your lego!
How are you supposed to poop?
You're literally lego!
Guys, we're almost there!
There's the bathroom!
We're almost there!
Use the bathroom!
With the lego on poop.
Smaller lego.
Alright.
Yay!
Now you're happy again.
Thank fucking god!
How are you mad?
You- I- Okay, I am a good person.
I don't understand how you can be mad.
I don't understand.
Yay!
Oh!
He can't be that strong!
Yeah, it's a level 3!
You guys got this!
It's a level 3!
One of us is happy with the other.
Come on guys!
Look, this is why I love Gray- This is exactly why Gray Agumon is like my favorite.
Oh no!
Use your bubble!
Help him!
Help your bro-
Help your fucking brother!
Oh no!
Okay, nice.
That's good.
Use your claws!
Snow Agumon!
Go in there!
Okay.
Oh, I can use the big one!
What am I doing?
Oh, I can use Blizzard!
Why help him?
He's the favorite.
Cause he's your brother!
You're supposed to love each other!
Without family- You can't go through the world without the bond of your brother!
Yay!
Good job!
You did great guys!
You did great!
Yeah, Green Man's Digi- Evolution info.
Oh, I got- I got Gatomon?
Wait, I can still evolve to Gatomon!
It's so fun!
This is why you're my favorite!
Wait!
He can still be Gatomon?
Okay.
Oh my god.
I still- still hope.
There's still hope for you!
There's still hope!
The dream is alive!
The dream is still alive!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
It's still alive!
We still have a chance to get Gatomon!
We still have a chance to get a cat!
You were supposed to be Terriermon!
But we can still get a cat!
We can still get a- We can still get a cat!
Okay.
That's good!
Alright.
Oh shit!
I should be healing!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
We gotta heal.
Wait.
Both of you got the heals?
Nice.
Alright.
Make sure you get that.
And I'll make sure you use a bubble.
Beat it up!
Beat up the plant!
We don't need more oxygen in the world.
Look!
I healed!
Nice.
Go!
Help your brother!
Alright.
And then bubble.
Use the bubble!
Nice one!
Why does it keep fucking beating up SnowGreymon?
Or Agumon?
Nice hit!
Alright.
Cheer!
You missed!
No!
Your brother!
Your brother needs her!
Fucking help your brother!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Let him get hit!
We're doing a lot with him!
He's a favorite!
He can take it!
No!
Oh wait!
He can come to the city!
What can I say?
I'm a gourmand!
This is a momentous occasion indeed!
You see, I won five green digi stocks.
I don't have them.
Sorry.
I don't have the digi stocks.
Oh no!
You need a bandaid?
Okay, don't worry.
I got you.
Uh... We need to give you a bandaid.
Alright.
There you go.
You're healed now.
Oh thank god.
It's okay.
You're okay now.
Toy Agumon knows that he's not the favorite.
He's like not even happy.
Alright.
Grab the wood.
Guys.
Yes.
I can collect one more time.
Okay, I'll collect one more time.
Alright.
Dragoon... Dragoon...
Dragoon 4 is...
Dragoon 3 is still mad.
Why are you still mad?
Oh no!
Oh no.
This is bad.
This is really bad.
Uh...
We gotta make sure that he's okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
I need...
Your brother does not want to help.
Oh thank god.
Okay.
Help!
Help him!
Stop running away!
Dragoon 3!
Your brother needs help!
You were born together!
Go for it!
That's how you do it!
Oh no.
Please!
He's getting... Brother!
I refuse.
It's his battle.
You guys were born together!
What happened to the brotherly bonds?
What happened?
Okay.
Uh...
We're gonna use claws.
Oh I missed.
I keep forgetting that you have to be closer together.
Toki happens.
No Bros got this.
All you do is run away!
Why?
I don't...
Why do you back up?
Just attack him!
You just...
You're letting your brother do all the work!
Like...
He's just a one-eyed...
He can't...
WALK UP TO HIM!
Holy shit.
It's called dodging.
I'm scared.
Oh the gas...
How?
How are you out of MP?
Oh my god.
You're still walking away!
I...
used it.
Oh my god.
Your brother at least is trying his best here.
This is exactly why Snow Agumon is my favorite.
This is why Dragoon IV is my favorite.
This is exactly why.
Please.
Why?
How is you still not recharging MP enough?
Nice one!
You never train our MP.
Holy shit.
Oh no.
How do I leave this area?
I'm fucked up.
I walked the wrong way.
Oh no.
They're still chasing me.
Oh he's gone.
Okay we gotta pick up this apple.
He's not a fighter.
He's a dancer.
Oh I got an apple!
Alright.
At least he's happy.
Alright we got it.
Oh there's another green sock.
I'm a lego.
What about being a little brother?
Always throw your brother under the bus.
Rule 2.
Take credit afterwards.
Why are you mad?
What do you want?
Dragoon III.
Or IV.
No you're IV.
You're III.
IV is better.
Yeah.
Sorry I lost track of the numbers.
Because you don't love him.
I am a lego.
Alright we got it.
It doesn't recharge?
That is not true.
Drag- oh wait there's a- There's a mushroom here.
Dragoon IV's- Dragoon IV's MP recharge.
Dragoon IV's MP recharge.
Why didn't your MP recharge?
Dragoon III?
Dragoon III.
Where was your recharge?
Dragoon IV is the golden child.
Wait you're hungry?
Okay we'll get food when we're home.
We'll get food when we're home.
Guys we're almost home.
He's a lion.
I scolded you once.
Because you wouldn't eat mushrooms.
I scolded you one time.
Just one time.
Because you were being a picky eater.
And I'm the bad guy.
Oh you don't like this item?
Bad.
Bad Dragoon.
Now eat.
No.
Good.
Now you're hungry.
Now we're gonna have our fill.
See?
Dragoon.
This Dragoon likes it.
Alright let's see.
I need to...
Dragoon III I don't understand why you don't like...
Why don't you like the mushrooms?
Alright how's your bond with me?
Not so great.
Hey!
You can't tell...
Which one's the favorite child.
I wonder why.
Why?
Dragoon IV.
You're doing great sweetie.
You're doing great Dragoon IV.
Dragoon III!
Why are you running away from your mom?
Okay.
Let's see.
Um...
How do I get you to...
What do I need to train you for?
Uh...
He doesn't even want you close.
Alright.
Oh there's a chance you might evolve into Wizard Mom because you're malnourished!
Oh no!
Oh my god!
There's a chance you're gonna be a wizard mom.
You don't have the weight.
I didn't mean to!
Oh yeah.
GG!
Do you have like...
So I've collected all the information about all the Digimon in the city borders.
I've asked Botemon over there to help you with everything that we learned.
If you ever fix, just talk to Botemon, okay?
Don't forget!
Oh, I thought he has like free stuff.
Dragoon.
Dragoon 4.
You're doing great.
You're doing so great.
I can't wait for you to turn into a cat soon.
You're my favorite.
Dragoon 3.
Get over here.
Dragoon 3!
Get over here!
Let's see...
Starving.
Can you find food?
What about us?
What do I want to get?
I want... Oh yeah.
I want to explore more.
Are we fully healed?
How do we heal up?
Do we just rest?
Guys, how do we heal up?
He's actually running away.
How do we heal up?
Go to the resting?
Oh, here?
Sharpen your skills!
Alright.
Rest.
I don't know.
Ask our brother.
There we go.
Oh my god!
I don't know what to train you guys for.
I don't know.
What was the idea for Gaonomon?
Alright.
Oh, you need to poop.
Okay, don't worry.
I'll take you guys to the bathroom.
Alright, time to poop, guys.
Time to poop.
I like how all of you guys associate stuff with like...
with like, Dragoon...
Oh yeah.
Stop being mad!
Your brother doesn't like it when you're mad!
Dragoon...
Stop being mad!
Dragoon 3.
Dragoon 4 doesn't like it when you're mad!
We want attention.
I'm giving you guys attention!
It's not my fault you fucking won't eat mushrooms!
Alright.
Let's go.
Is there anything here?
Is there?
I feel like...
We got to go this way.
Oh wait.
Do we have...
How do we save?
Oh, there it is.
Wow!
We did not save our game!
Okay, but who's Dragoon...
But who's Dragoon 4 in my chat?
Alright, let's go this way.
Where am I supposed to go anyway?
Map.
I'm here.
Where's star?
Material spot.
Fishing hole.
There's fishing?
Oh, there's fishing!
Oh, that's cool.
I volunteer.
Oh, he's level 2!
Get him!
It's a goblin!
I would rather die than be...
Wait!
They're not fully healed yet!
What?
I thought they... I rested!
They're not rest?
Inside you there are two Dragoons.
Oh no, oh no, no, no, no, no.
Help!
Help your brother!
He's gonna die!
Get up!
No!
Oh my god.
Wake up!
How do you heal?
I don't understand.
Not live the game.
I didn't know he was gonna die!
I thought your brother was gonna help you!
Good aim!
I thought he was a favorite child!
That's why he got instantly rest!
And then when Dragoon...
When Dragoon 3...
died, I fucking just ran.
Nice.
Yay!
Oh, we got some MP discs too.
The battle and your partner's return.
Yay!
You did great guys!
Great job!
You got...
Gardenmon, you got Gatomon, did you?
Oh!
Speed!
Oh, bonds!
Okay!
Okay, we gotta figure out...
Okay, I gotta pick up this apple though.
Okay.
How do I... So how do they heal?
I don't wanna use my items.
Oh god, it's night time.
What the fuck?
I did not expect it to be night time.
Oh, sleep at the end of the day.
Okay.
Alright, Gatomon.
Bond is there.
Speed is not.
Okay, we gotta train up your speed, guys.
Uh... Okay.
This is not good that like, uh...
It's not good that the weight portion is satisfied.
So we gotta...
We gotta make sure that...
I mean, Wizardmon's pretty cool.
Oh, speed isn't important.
Oh, it has no speed.
Okay.
I get it.
I get it now.
Speed does not matter.
Alright, let's get all the materials.
Okay, nice.
I like how we're using Dragoon 3 to farm the wood.
Oh, no!
Okay, Dragoon 4 is helping!
Nice.
Uh... Map.
Okay.
Map time.
Wait, how do I...
There is a subquest right here.
We're just gonna run from that.
Real quick.
Oh!
Oh, no, no, no, no, stop chasing!
Stop chasing!
I wanna talk to him!
It's Tentamon!
I was thinking around these parts.
Hey, wait a minute.
Are you one of them humans?
Boy, howdy!
It must have been fate that brought us together.
I saw something tell you, in fact.
So what do you think?
Have I piped your interest?
Or do you want us...
I should pick your nose instead?
Uh...
Go on and pick it.
Oh!
What the fuck?
Have I picked your interest?
Or... Well, alright.
Okay.
Alright.
I could tell you were a sharp one.
Now then, check out this...
Batten Boy.
Ta-da!
A recovery chest!
Just what every tamer needs.
I can let it go for now a hundred bits.
Uh...
Sure, I'll do it.
Thanks.
Really?
Well then, pleasure doing business with you, partner!
Thanks to you, I can finally open my item shop!
I'll have more deals down the line!
So give me a holler in town!
Peace out, hombre!
Yeah!
Tentamon!
Tentamon has joined the army!
Alright, let's see... We have to head to... Uh...
Oh, fishing!
How do I fish?
Oh, I don't have a fishing rod.
Not yet.
Oh, wait!
Can you guys farm this?
Yeah, grab some stones!
Grab some stones, dragons!
Farm the stone, dragon 3!
Come on, dragon 3!
You can still do it!
Farm harder!
Use your lego hands!
Mom, my brother hit me!
Stop hitting each other!
Oh, I can't carry any more materials.
Okay.
Guys, you guys gotta stop hitting each other!
Alright?
You guys were born together!
We are a family!
I love you both equally!
You both share the same amount of love I have for the both of you, despite some failures on one of you guys.
That's a lie!
Oh, Beelmon!
Here I go!
Dang it!
Can't do it!
I wanna fly all through the sky!
The thing is though, I'm not very good at it.
Won't someone teach me how to fly?
Um...
I don't think it's possible.
Keep trying!
You can do it, Beelmon!
I will!
Thanks!
If you meet any Digimon that could give some pointers, please let me know!
Wait, do I need like a Digimon that can fly?
What's this?
Oh!
I got fruit!
Oh, I need like a Digimon that can fly to help them.
...
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
So far, this game has had pooping and picking boogers.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, why Pokemon was more successful.
Well, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you, Rassan!
Um...
I think like... No, I just need you guys to know, Digimon World 1 was so hardcore.
It was like, a lot more brutal than it is!
Because like, if they, if they are, if they need to use the bathroom, they will poop on the floor.
They'll do it!
And like, you do not have time to... You do not have time to take them to the bathroom.
Got a second?
Made my day!
Oh, I got...
Yeah, I got a Tentamon!
Yeah, he's gonna open up an item shop!
I got two now!
Okay.
Nice!
Alright.
You're hungry?
Oh, they poop on the floor here too?
...
I knew like, they poop on the floor, but they also like, um... Okay, we're gonna feed you guys mushrooms.
Here you go!
Here's a mushroom for you!
Alright, maybe I should give you guys...
Are you guys tired?
Are you guys still hungry?
Why are you guys still hungry?
Fine!
I'll give you guys meat!
There you go!
Are you guys happier now?
See?
Okay, someone said I need to talk to a specific mon.
Um, to get free items.
There's a plant-type Digimon in Nine Plains who wants some kind of material.
A bug-type Digimon has been spotted in the forest.
And there's a Digimon in need of a good meal in the forest.
Oh, that's the one that wants the green mushrooms.
Alright.
Which one talked to Kuromon?
Which one was Kuromon again?
Is this Kuromon?
Okay, no.
That's... Are you Kur... No, that's Tokomon.
What is Kuromon?
What does Kuromon look like?
...
Are you Kuromon?
No, you're Poyomon.
I can never rem... Oh!
I talked to everybody but Kuromon!
...
Sorry.
I don't remember what the babies look like.
I only remember like the rookies and the champions.
The baby names are like so hard to remember.
Let's see.
I need you to be the cat.
I just want you to be a cat.
It's hot.
You need to sleep?
You're not tired yet, right guys?
I don't think you guys are tired yet.
So we can go... We can go outside.
and explore a little bit longer.
We sleep when...
We sleep when I see you be tired.
Not until you see the ZZZ.
Oh!
What would...
What would make him a cat?
Guys.
Toy... Toy Agumon is like...
Um... No.
It's hopeless.
But I can still...
...
Dragoon... Dragoon 4?
I have potential in Dragoon 4.
Dragoon 3, you're hopeless.
But Dragoon 4, you have potential still.
Uh...
It is wisdom.
Wait.
What?
Wisdom for both?
I think they hit wisdom already, didn't they?
Yeah.
Oh no.
Okay.
Wisdom.
Keep getting stronger!
Mom, calm me.
Don't worry.
We can remake you.
You're not forever hopeless.
The moment...
You still have potential.
In your next life.
You still have potential in your next life.
Alright.
We're giving you MP.
Just because you have none of that.
Yay!
Alright.
Let's see.
We have... Oh, you need a poop?
Okay.
We gotta take you outside.
It seems satisfied with their new strength.
You guys did it!
Don't worry.
Dragoon 4.
You're gonna be so smart.
Guardmon.
Okay.
We don't care about Guardmon.
Alright.
Go poop now.
Go poop.
Oh, I keep forgetting there's a bathroom like next to us.
Alright.
Speed?
What does Guardmon mean?
Uh...
I keep forgetting that.
Speed doesn't...
What does...
What does Guardmon mean?
HP?
A bit of strength?
Don't need speed.
Okay.
Wisdom and MP.
Uh...
We'll just give you...
We'll give you a defense.
Just because I don't know what else to do with you.
Dragoon 3.
Yay!
I've got a star!
Alright.
Nice.
Yeah!
Oh, now you wanna sleep.
Alright, guys.
We're gonna go sleep now.
Let's sleep.
Let's sleep outside.
We're gonna look at the stars tonight.
We're gonna sleep outside.
With all the other babies.
Yay!
We recovered.
We've recovered everything.
Alright.
Let's grab some meat, guys.
Yay!
Alright.
Feeding time!
Come over here, Dragoons!
It's time to eat!
Time to eat!
There you go!
Yay!
You're still hungry?
Okay.
We're giving you mushrooms.
You ate too much, guys.
It's mushroom time.
You gotta eat your veggies.
You gotta balance it with veggies and meat.
I need you to be the ultimate ultimate weight.
Oh, we can get more free stuff.
Alright.
Give me more free stuff.
Yay!
We got medicine!
Nice.
Alright, guys.
Let's go!
Let's go.
We need to...
We need to go find more Digimon.
To bring back into town.
And we have to make sure...
I need you to Digivolve into a cat.
That's all I want.
Dragoons 3, you can just like...
I don't know...
Be there.
You can watch your brother Digivolve into a cat.
You don't have to...
You don't have to advance from Lego if you don't want to.
Um...
Let's see.
We gotta go...
Where do I have to go?
Where are we?
We're like here.
To the forest path.
Uh...
Materialist spot.
Fishing spot.
Oh, we can like go talk to this one.
Life is pain as a Lego.
I love all Dragoons equally!
You still have potential!
Dragoon 3.
This way.
Alright.
I'm trying to figure out how to...
I want to know what this Digimon wants.
To come to my town.
Alright, let's go.
God!
The way you run!
Some fucking off-brand Lego shit right there!
...
I love all my Digimon equally.
Alright.
Yes, I've come at a good time!
I need help with something!
I'm looking for fertilizer to help me make some tasty meat.
But I'm having a little trouble.
That's where you come from.
No problem.
Thanks, you're the best!
Bring me a cheerful apple, a digi stalk, and some salty fruit.
We need to find them.
Got it?
Okay.
Salty fruit.
Where do I get salty fruit?
I don't think I've ever seen a salty fruit before.
Just admit that you hate us?
I don't!
I love Dragon 4!
...
I like how we go into this ring.
Nice one!
That's the way!
Nice.
Stronger power level.
That's good!
... Oh my god!
See?
At least Dragon 4 hubs!
...
Wait a minute...
That's the way!
Come on, Dragon 4!
Make Mommy proud!
Go, 4!
Go!
3.
Don't take your brother's spotlight.
Let your younger brother have the spotlight.
...
2.
3.
4!
You did it!
Oh my!
You did amazing!
...
There are 4 systems and tamer skills.
And 3 to 5 subsystems within these.
Switch between these systems.
Oh!
Press A to look for subsystems.
Oh my god, this is a lot more elaborate than I expected.
...
Um...
Getting a skill is not possible until the skills before that one have been acquired.
Press A on the skill panel to acquire the skills.
Oh!
What the heck?
What the fuck?
...
This is like so complicated.
What's this?
Small bonus during the bond boost.
Oh!
It's treat type, life type, reverse type.
Boost parameter inheritance by 1 level.
Oh!
I would like that.
Yeah.
Uh...
If you are a tamer in a lower region, you will definitely be able to acquire all skills.
So learn the ones you need.
Okay.
I really want to learn this one.
What's the best one to have?
Um...
There are so many skill sets.
Yeah, I felt like the egg would be the best because...
Uh...
Um...
Walker type for free heal?
Where's the free heal?
Oh, here!
...
Heal while running is good.
Okay, we'll get that one next.
Um...
Let's see...
History...
Have you unlocked it yet?
Okay, we still have the bonds for it.
Uh...
But other than that, we don't really have anything else.
What the fuck is Gajramon?
Good.
Okay, where do we need to go?
Okay, I want to go this way.
I think there might be...
We might be able to find the fruit here.
Defend order is good.
Defend... um...
Walker.
Okay, we'll get Walker.
What the fuck?
Oh, it's...
Uh, what's your name?
It's Vemon!
The blockhead Togmon.
Even though my special move is so cool and strong...
I'll never go back there.
Hmph!
What's this?
Are you a human?
What are you doing in a place like this?
Is this your first time here?
Wait, there's like...
fucking servers here.
Why are there servers in my desert?
Hahahaha!
This is server desert.
A place devoid of vegetation after intense heat from old servers withered all the plants away.
Oh, that's clever.
This is my space.
Hahahaha!
The old break room called Oasis has a vending machine and a toilet.
Out here, a tower of new type servers lies deep within.
Um...
And out west, a ways to reach wasteland.
South of here lies another area called Logic Volcano.
Um...
But beware, the Digimon out there are stronger than the ones you'll face in Nine Plains.
Are you coming home with us?
That...
Oh wait, are you telling me this again?
Oh wait, oh, did he introduce this again?
Cryptomine killed the planets.
Plants.
Oh my god.
Hahahaha!
What was that really intense game that's known to like be used to test PCs?
I remember you guys wanted me to try it out because the game was like Oh no, you guys need to use the bathroom.
You need to go back.
No!
Oh my god!
I wanted to get to the bathroom!
Crisis, yeah.
This is all the PCs that are trying to run Crisis right now.
Hahaha!
Alright, keep going!
Keep going guys!
Dragoons, keep fighting!
What level are you guys anyway?
Oh no.
Oh no, your brother is always getting hurt!
You have to help him!
Let's go!
Your brother is always getting hurt, guys!
Help your brother!
Help him!
Dragoons, help your younger brother!
He needs help!
Hahaha!
Alright, we gotta We gotta take you to the bathroom.
I'm heading there, I'm heading there guys!
Give me a sec!
We're getting there as fast as our little feets can take us!
Little feetsies!
It's right over there!
I don't know why.
I don't know why!
Dragoons 3, why don't you like your younger brother?
You're older, so you have the experience to teach him!
You gotta take care of him!
You guys have shared the same blood!
Nononononono He's faster than me!
Nonononono!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm not gonna waste my porta-potty.
I'm not, I'm not gonna waste...
I would rather you poop on the floor then use my porta-potty.
I gotta, I gotta save up.
The same DigiBlood.
155.
Jesus.
Our bond is like half.
Alright.
Let's go this way.
We gotta run faster than...
Faster than these guys.
Like these guys are...
Are so strong.
Oh my god, they're level 3.
They're level 3.
There's so many of them too.
We gotta run past all of them.
Alright.
I don't hate you guys.
You're all equal.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Oh my god, oh my god.
No!
God damn it.
Oh god, I need to use items.
Uh...
Let's see.
Oh, I have a lot more.
Good, I still have a lot more.
Don't even take any damage.
Dragoon 3.
Alright, nice.
Come on.
Come on, you guys got this.
Keep fighting.
I'm cheering you guys on.
We're together.
Oh no.
What?
Dragoon 4.
How could you miss?
Dragoon 4, please.
Dragoon 3, help your little brother out.
He can't aim.
He doesn't have the hand-eye coordination.
He's trying his best.
Bro-cat aim.
Yay!
You did it, Dragoon 3!
We have to describe items?
Return to town.
Wisdom chip.
Oh wait, I can like increase your...
your...
I can increase you guys.
Oh no, I don't know what to throw away.
Oh, this is going to be difficult.
Ooh.
What do I throw away?
Get rid of the autopilot.
Do we not need that?
Alright.
Discard.
Alright, guys.
Apparently, I didn't even realize I had items that can increase your stats.
So I don't have to train you guys anymore.
Alright, which one is it?
Which one do I need to give Dragoon 4?
For Gatomon.
What do I need?
Give all wisdom and HP.
Okay, wisdom.
Alright.
Oh, you both get it?
God, I didn't...
You're not supposed to be smarter.
Oh, just...
Okay, just you.
Okay, nice.
Alright, I figured it out.
Alright.
MP as well.
Wisdom and MP.
Okay, here you go.
You deserve this.
Yay!
Don't worry.
You deserve this.
Good job.
Good job, Dragoon 4.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
No!
What's the way did he come from?
Wait!
Keep your eyes open.
Where the fuck...
Please!
What gets out of you aim?
I raised you guys to be aimers.
I raised...
I raised you guys to be able to aim.
I don't understand.
Alright.
Come on.
Come on, Dragoon 3.
Okay, I'm gonna use this.
Okay.
We should be able...
That should be like one hit for him.
It did not register?
Oh, wait.
I used agitation.
No.
Okay.
There we go.
Blizzard.
This should do it.
Brother ain't that smart even with all...
No, I mean, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Now I can talk.
Please.
I just want to talk to him.
It's no good.
I can't think of anything.
I may be weak, but I want to help people.
The problem is my only skill is making this thread.
I can't think of anything.
I'm confident in strength, but what can I use it for?
A fishing line.
Fishing line.
What a great idea.
Even I could make something like that.
Oh, this is where we get the fishing rod.
I don't have anything I could use as a fishing rod.
Can you help me find a stick?
Sure.
I wonder if I could use it as a rod.
Bring it here.
I'm counting on you.
How am I gonna get a stick?
Oh, God.
Leave me alone.
Please leave me alone.
Please.
I need to go find a stick.
Wait, do I have enough items?
I should have enough items to feed them, right?
I need like five.
No, I only have two.
I didn't kill enough Digimon for more of the mushrooms.
Oh, no.
I'm gonna run away.
Yeah, let me grab this first.
Nice.
I'm gonna go back to the gaming.
Okay.
I need to go back to give the food to the... give food to the one, the other Digimon.
I'm for the chooks.
All right, here we go.
God, I just want to evolve you into Gatomon.
I can't believe it.
No, please.
No.
All right.
I missed the stick.
No.
It's okay.
We have to go this way anyway.
Run, run, run.
No, we have to go this way anyway.
That's fine.
Where is he?
Where's the quest line for this?
Oh, it's over there.
I went around the wrong way.
It's over there.
Don't worry.
We're heading there.
Run, run, run.
Okay.
Don't worry.
We'll find another stick, guys.
We can always find...
There's trees everywhere.
Surely one of them can be a stick.
All right.
Nice.
Here we go.
Hello.
Hello, plant lady.
Yes.
I got everything.
Yay!
Powmon joined the city.
Okay.
We can find another stick.
There has to be another stick over there.
There's no way.
Something's here or something's there.
Really?
Here we go.
One.
I don't think I see anything here.
Okay.
We'll go through...
Is it this way?
No.
It was like...
Oh my God.
I'm ready.
How am I lost?
How am I...
Oh, it's this way.
Okay.
I was going to say, how am I...
How am I lost?
Is this only like...
How did it caught up to me?
Oh my God.
Please leave me alone.
Leave us alone.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
It's working.
Way to go!
I wish I could run away faster, dude.
That's all I wish for.
Alright.
Use your...
Oh.
I shouldn't have done that.
Bigay!
Oh, no.
No!
No!!
Your brother!!
Oh, No.
Live!
Here you go.
Live!!
Why do you always let your brother die!?
Okay.
That's the way.
Why do you never... I keep forgetting how low HP he is!
Younger brother!
You gotta help your younger brother!
Help your younger brother!
Go!
No MP.
Why do you always run out of MP?
MP!
Oh my god.
Dragon 4, you did great.
Dragon 3, you were there.
Oh, we got Greymon.
What's TF?
What the fuck is TF?
We got the TF part.
Okay.
And then, let's see...
I don't even know.
I hope we get there for like the other stuff.
Oh, training failure?
You failed?
How did you fail?
How did you fail training?
How the fuck...
I didn't even let you guys poop on the floor.
When did you guys poop on the floor?
Oh, the mistakes!
Oh!
Oh, I see.
I see.
You don't hit the icons.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna go back.
Okay, we're gonna give you guys food, actually.
We're gonna make sure you guys have food.
Uh...
Alright, I'm gonna give you guys...
I'm gonna give you guys regular meat.
And then... Oh, wait.
I just fed one of you guys.
Oops.
Sorry.
You need food too.
Give me...
Sorry.
I only fed one of you.
Don't worry.
Here you go.
I almost didn't feed you too.
I don't...
Alright, let's go back.
It's time to train.
It's time to train again.
Yay!
We got Palmon!
On Proof of Feels!
Alright, we gotta go and...
We gotta go and give you more training.
Oh, Palmon!
What are you gonna do?
Oh, they're gonna up like the amount of stuff there.
Alright.
What does... What does, uh...
Dragon 4 need?
I'll give you more MP.
Cause you're... You need more of that.
Um...
What does Dragon 4 need more of?
No, Dragon 4 has a lot of love.
Oh, 4 Wisdom?
What are they now?
Partner...
Uh, Status.
Let's see... He's only at 207.
Holy shit!
You need so much Wisdom!
Yay!
We got the Heart Bonus!
Nice.
Okay, 100... 240.
Alright, more.
Alright.
Okay.
Yay!
Plus 33.
Plus 7.
Plus 65.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, don't worry.
I'll take you to the bathroom!
600 Wisdom and 7900...
Jeez!
You guys have... Are you guys too tired?
Not yet?
Or are you guys good?
Okay, I can still train you guys a little more.
Alright.
Go.
Uh...
Go do your thing.
Yay!
We got another Bonus!
See, plus 33.
Plus 65.
Um...
Nice.
Alright.
I mean, I guess you're slowly getting smarter.
Are you tired?
I'm tired.
Dragon 4 wasn't tired.
How are you tired?
It's tears.
Yay!
We got another Bonus!
Let's go!
I'm getting better at this.
Alright, 65.
65, 33... okay, wisdom is almost there.
We're almost there for wisdom.
Oh, are you guys hungry?
Oh, Dragon 4, you're hungry?
Don't worry.
Mama's here to feed you.
Alright, here, have some meat.
What are you doing?
You're not Dragon 4.
I guess you can have some meat as well.
Alright, you're full.
Yay!
I need to remember to have both selected.
Oh wait.
That's not what I want to do.
Alright, time for more training guys!
It's training again!
Yeah!
More bonus!
Let's see... 65, 33...
Alright, that's good.
I'm just going to keep training.
I'm just going to keep training you guys until you're done.
I'm going to be here until I get got them on.
Yeah!
Okay, plus 33, plus 65.
Alright, one of you guys need to poop.
I'll take you.
One of you guys go to the bathroom break.
And then...
And then you.
We got to feed you.
Hello!
Alright, um...
Jesus.
How are you...
Dragon 3, how are you still so unhappy?
How are you still...
How are you...
I don't understand.
How are you still unhappy?
I feed you.
Stay focused.
We're going to keep training until we get got them on.
Until we get a cat.
That's all I want.
I'm here.
Night.
Alright, you're gonna sleep in the gym.
We're gonna sleep in the gym.
Alright, time to eat!
It's breakfast time!
Alright, you guys gotta lose weight, so I'm gonna feed you guys mushrooms now.
You both need to lose weight, guys.
I've been feeding you guys too much meat.
Okay, an apple with a smile to make you... Yeah!
Let's give you guys an apple too.
You guys lose weight with apple?
Completely full.
HP recovered by 10.
Oh, it's just mixed like... Holy shit!
How did you get sad?
How did you hate me more?
You lost your sadness!
Wait!
How did he lose his sad...
He hates me more now!
I don't understand!
Why does he hate me more?
What did I do?
What did I do to him?
Alright, 30, 60...
We're almost there.
We just need two more.
Alright, we're gonna go out to grab some food.
They seem satisfied with their new strength and training.
You did great, Dragos!
You did great!
Got Sorcerer's Mons, got Guard's Mons, Evil Geese...
Got the Solution.
We gotta grab some more meat though.
Eight!
Nice!
We now have eight meat.
We gotta store some stuff though.
Store.
We're holding way too much stuff.
I'll put seven.
And then...
I'll put the Porta Potties.
Uh...
Shady, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Training will continue until happiness increases.
Alright.
We need more wisdom.
Do I have enough wisdom?
I don't remember if I like...
No, I don't.
I only have these.
Oh, I have MP.
Oh, wait.
Now that restores.
Alright, back to training you go!
Guys, we're not leaving until...
We're not leaving until...
One of you guys turn into the cat!
Where should we put...
Where should we put Dragoon 3, guys?
Where...
Where do we put Dragoon 3?
Let's see...
Strength?
Alright, we'll put you in Strength.
Strength.
Yay!
Bonus!
Plus 28, plus 55.
Oh my god, we're almost there.
We need like 100 more.
Alright, bathroom break.
I got stronger into Spider.
Yeah!
We got the bonus!
128 you go.
We're so close.
Okay, uh...
Okay, we're gonna keep going.
I like how all the bonuses are on the other Dragoon.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
We're almost there.
Okay, I'll let you sleep.
You're not leaving this gym!
Don't hold back!
Your brother has to become a cat!
If it's the last thing I do!
Alright,
let's do it.
Keep going.
Yay!
Oh shit, you're hungry.
Sorry, I forgot to feed you guys.
Uh, items.
Time to eat!
And then... nice!
Okay.
Oh shit, not you.
God damn it!
I keep forgetting to feed the other!
I keep forgetting to do the all button!
Okay, there we go.
Now I'll feed both of them.
And then... come on!
Come eat!
My favorite child!
If I have a favorite but I don't...
Alright, back to the gym you go!
Yay!
Bonus!
Let's see...
Alright, that should be it, right?
I'm tired out.
Is that it?
Yes.
Rest.
Three finally smiled.
Oh yeah!
You guys did great!
Three!
Okay, I need MP now.
Alright, go to the bathroom.
I need less weight?
Oh my god.
Alright, it's time to go on a diet, Dragoon 4.
Dragoon 4, you gotta go on a diet for mommy.
We gotta find some mushrooms.
We gotta find some veggies.
Dragoon 3, you can eat as much as you want.
I don't really care.
But like, Dragoon 4!
If you want the talent scouts to choose you and say you're special cause you're mommy's special little Digimon, you gotta lose some weight.
Alright?
We'll eat this food.
That's on...
This is a pattern telling you certain Evos have weight maximum of 14.
Okay, we're gonna fucking need to find some mushrooms for you.
We gotta find you some vegetables.
You gotta find you some vegetables so you can be a hot and... hot... hot angelmon.
Wait, what was it?
What was it?
Angelwoman!
Oh yeah, it was Angelwoman.
Cause after that you go!
Wait, two of the... Level 4?!
Holy shit!
Oh my...
Oh
no.
Oh no.
Um... I'm trying...
No, don't cry.
Don't cry.
I got... I got the bandaid!
Here you go!
Oh, thank god.
Oh, you're not dead.
Oh, I thought you guys died.
I... I thought...
After... I thought after everything...
After all the time I spent on trying to get you into... a cat!
I thought I lost all the progress!
Oh, you're still alive!
Thank god!
Oh, thank god they're still alive!
Oh my god, I thought they died.
Holy shit!
Anyway, back to training you go.
It's MP time.
Alright, MP and then I guess you can do strength.
Alright, back to the gym you go.
Back to...
Back to training.
All she cares about is the dumb cat.
That's the king, right?
Here you go.
Eat your mushrooms.
You gotta lose weight.
Alright.
Okay, uh...
This one you get meat.
You can eat meat if you want.
Okay.
Get it.
Alright, nice.
Alright, time to train.
Training again.
Yay!
Bonus!
Let's see.
We're almost there.
Alright, and then... more bonus.
Yeah!
God, I'm so good at this.
So good at this game.
Okay.
Potty break!
Yay!
Alright, it's...
We're good to go.
Alright, you guys.
Are you guys happy with mommy?
Wait, we gotta put some stuff away.
Uh...
Store.
I don't think we need any of the chips anymore.
We need more of the green mushrooms though.
Um... 4000 MP?
Wait, it needs 4000?
I thought it was 3000.
7000... 7800 for a cat?
Alright, I need you to eat this disc.
I need...
Oh no, that's the restore.
God damn, I keep thinking that's the...
It's 7800... Back to the gym.
We're not leaving the gym.
We're gonna try...
Train until you're a cat.
Wait a minute.
Holy shit!
What do you mean a 7800?
What?
Oh shit, it was...
Doesn't wanna wake up?
Who doesn't wanna wake up?
Dragon 3.
Stop that!
Bad dragon!
Listen to your tamer!
I wanna eat!
Holy shit!
Dragon 4 was like, listen to your tamer, I wanna eat!
Here you go!
There we go.
Holy shit.
Dragon 4 is like, listen to your tamer, I wanna eat!
Dragon 4?
Dragon 4 is like, let me be ledge language...
Dragon 5, come join us.
No, no, no need to come here.
Mommy!
Alright, here, have some meat.
Dragon 3 needs some vacation.
Alright, it's time for you to lose weight, Mori.
You're still not the ideal weight.
Alright, nice.
Okay, we gotta find plants though.
Let's go back.
And then we're gonna grab some...
Let's get some meat.
Alright, we gotta find some...
We gotta find some plants for you.
MP 7800, Wisdom 600.
Jesus Christ!
That's a lot of wisdom!
Oh my god!
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We need to find plants so you can lose weight!
Gatomon!
Gatomon is like skinny.
You're too flabby right now.
How the fuck do I find the mushrooms?
These mushrooms are so hard to find!
We need to get MP!
Just go to Battle Winds.
You're right, maybe I should just get Battle Winds.
But I still need mushrooms though.
I need to find mushrooms.
How the fuck... where are the mushrooms?
Okay guys, we need to walk around until we get mushrooms.
Wait, what?
Nooooooo!
No!
You better evolve into a fucking cat!
Yes!
You're a cat!
Oh my god, look at you!
You're so cute!
Not you.
Look at you!
Ready?
I...
I got the cat!
Aaaaa!
Oh my god!
You're mommy's favorite!
Look at you!
This damn cat!
You're mommy's favorite!
I got the cat!
You're so cute!
Look at him!
Let's pick this up.
What level is that?
Oh shit, level 3?
We should be fine.
We should be fine with level 3.
Oh, look at you!
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
I thought...
How strong is he?
No, no, restore 500.
Go get... No!
No!
Are you okay?
Are you okay, Drago4?
Drago4, are you okay?
Drago4?
I'm so sorry!
Mommy's sorry!
Are you okay?
Don't worry, mommy's got you.
I got the recovery disc.
I got the recovery disc for you.
I got the recovery disc for both of you.
It's okay.
Mommy loves you, Drago4.
Here, I'll kiss your poo-poos.
Drago3, what are you doing?
Drago3.
You were supposed to protect your brother!
You were supposed to protect your younger brother, Drago3!
What were you doing?
Why would you let your older brother...
Why would you let your younger brother get hurt?
Why are you hurting him?!
Okay, let's see.
Oh my god, look, now you're a cat!
Look at that, Drago4!
Now you're a cat!
Oh my god, you're so cute!
Look at what they can piec up.
And they are raised with love!
Thank you the superchat Gio.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Alright, let's see.
We gotta go... let's go to the weaker areas.
Why are we like so weak?
Like where can we go?
I feel like we can't go anywhere because we're so weak.
Like where can I live?
I feel like I'm just weak.
Weak!
Because you're still level one.
Alright, let's go.
Alright.
I got them all!
Dragone 4!
Show me what you got!
Fight this!
Fight the goblin!
I wanna see how your strength is like!
Go!
Wait, maybe he's a little weak.
No, he's not weak.
Yeah!
Okay.
Lightning paw!
Show me the lightning paw!
I live at the gym!
A thousand damage!
Wait that's actually crazy.
Alright.
You guys did great!
Good job!
Good job everybody!
You got Taomon's...
Ability?
Okay, let's go grab this berry.
What's this?
Wait, what can you evolve into, Gatomon?
Okay, let's see.
Taomon.
Oh no, that's...
I want Angel Woman.
I want you to evolve into Angel Woman.
Alright, let's grab the mushrooms.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay.
Maybe there's like less people...
Maybe like...
They're hard... They're less hard here.
It's a power plant number two.
Maybe power plant number two.
Because I feel like everybody is so like overpowered.
Oh god, oh god.
Oh god, we gotta go.
We gotta go this way.
Oh, definitely not this way.
I saw level five.
Definitely not there.
Maybe the cableway?
Where the fuck do I go?
Why is everybody so strong?
Wait, it's two.
Okay, we're gonna have to use our items.
Recovery.
Nice.
Alright.
So, and then...
Use your metal claws.
Use it!
Go!
Punch him up!
Speed him up!
Come on, he's so low!
Yeah!
You go to the gym and live there forever!
But I don't wanna live in the gym!
I'm trying to find a stick right now!
Why is it so hard to find a stick?
I missed the gym!
Why is everybody so strong?
Oh, it's Dark Gobblemon!
Okay, we do not wanna mess with them.
We don't wanna mess with them.
Guys, we don't wanna mess with them.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that was scary.
I saw level six, but I didn't know what was going on.
Oh my god, we're so fucking dead.
We're so dead.
Okay, maybe there's a stick over there.
Maybe there's a stick over here.
Are there any sticks?
Are there any sticks here?
I fucked up.
That one time, I like...
That was actually so fucked up.
I did not realize that was like the one time I found the fucking elusive rare stick.
Back to the forest we go.
Come on.
Come on, three.
Your brother already leveled up.
You were born first, three.
Your brother's already leveled up.
What's stopping you from leveling up as well?
Come on!
If you wanna win mommy's love, you gotta...
You gotta earn it.
Look for the...
Oh, it's golden glowing patch.
Okay, it's gold.
Uh, three...
Late bloomer.
I love you enough!
You're supposed to make sure your brother's safe.
Uh, where the fuck are the sticks?
All I get is wood.
I wish you could stop digivolution.
Check the stats?
No, it's okay.
He'll evolve when he has to.
He'll digivolve when he has to.
Wait, I got sick?
Oh, I just got it?
I didn't even notice.
Okay.
I wanna make...
I want...
I want Gatomon to be a...
Be a cat forever.
Look!
Look at Gatomon run!
Look at her go!
Oh my god.
You're so cute!
All that effort I spent in making you the cutest paid off!
Oh, you need to eat.
Alright, gather around.
Now you can eat again!
Now...
Now you can both eat!
Wait, I wanna make...
I wanna feed both of you.
Why can't I feed both of you guys?
Oh, there you go.
Alright.
Now you both eat me!
Yay!
Time to eat!
Here you go!
You don't have to go on a diet anymore, Dragoon 4!
Alright, nice.
Alright, we're gonna give him a stick.
I'm gonna run around.
Wanna run away.
Okay.
Yes!
I got you a stick!
Pesto!
Fishing rod complete!
Could have done it without...
Without...
Yeah!
Now I can fish!
Okay, we gotta go home now.
No!
Of course.
I just literally...
Yeah!
Kick the plant!
Okay, I can't do anything.
Alright, go fight!
Go fight!
Okay, there you go.
Oh, critical hit!
Nice!
How did you miss?
Yeah!
Oh, nice!
We did it!
You guys did great!
I'm so proud of you, Dragoon 4!
Three?
Alright, what did you...
What...
Three, what are you gonna become?
Oh my god, finally!
You were such a late bloomer!
I wonder what he is gonna become though.
A man!
No!
No, no, no!
Oh god, oh god!
We gotta run!
Oh my
god!
We got...
It was meant to be!
We can't watch him die!
We can't give drama!
We...
Oh my god...
Blah!
Trapify!
Oh my god, we did it!
We saved Wizardmon!
Oh my god!
We actually saved Wizardmon!
He didn't die!
I'm so proud of you, Dragoon3.
Oh my god, I've always...
You were always a great... You were always a good Dragoon.
I actually got it!
I got the iconic duo!
I knew it!
My mistreatment of you, Dragoon3, was only so you can become Wizardmon!
It was... I did it out of love, Wizardmon!
Dragoon3, I did it out of love!
I needed you to become... I needed you to harden your heart.
You need to harden yourself so you can become Wizardmon!
What do you love?
It was for your own good!
Oh my god, I'm so happy!
I got Wizardmon and Gatomon!
We're canon now!
We're canon!
And we can fish!
It was DigiDestiny!
Exactly!
Thank you for the magenta super blade!
Thank you, thank you!
It was DigiDestiny!
Guys!
Okay, we need to get heals for you, Wizardmon.
You're fucked up right now.
All that time doing strength training just to get a wizard.
Look, it's because of my love that Dragoon3 became who he was supposed to be.
My love did this.
You guys doubted me, but there was a plan.
There was a whole plan.
Alright, let's go!
Oh, I got... yeah, I got...
You're back!
I have good news!
Made my day!
Mmm!
I can tell you what your partner's favorite fruit is!
The city's prosperity is now four!
There's still a long way to go!
I can't believe it!
Oh, we got recovery.
Nice, we actually needed that.
I can't believe it!
We actually got...
We actually got the dynamic duo!
A health runner.
Okay, we need that actually.
Yeah, we need health runner.
What else do we need?
That's low.
I hate the city contempt.
What is my... what is the other one that we need?
MP runner?
Lifetype?
Who's happy when... wait, what do we want then?
MP runner.
MP runner?
Oh, here!
Okay.
Yeah, we... oh, we don't have enough!
We don't have enough though.
We gotta save up.
I can't believe it.
I... I...
It's so funny!
I just saved...
I can't believe I actually got them!
Holy shit!
Alright, do I have enough HP recovery?
I don't remember if I withdraw any... if I...
Uh... no, I didn't.
Okay, we gotta buy some.
Buy some.
Oh, we're not... wait, you're not 100%?
Oh, you are.
Okay, bye.
Autopilot recovery disc.
Alright.
I'll buy one extra.
Give HP and strength to Gato.
The Dragoon IV.
Okay.
Um, HP, strength.
Alright.
Alright, Gato-mon!
Get over here!
I gotta give you HP and strength.
Alright, here.
Get more heals!
Cause mommy loves you!
And more strength!
Cause mommy really loves you!
Alright.
And Dragoon III, you're doing great.
Just don't die.
That's it.
Oh yeah, I was supposed to heal you!
Sorry!
Sorry, I need to take you back to the bed.
I forgot to heal you.
Give me a sec, I gotta go back to heal you.
Forgot the one most important thing.
Wait, so how do they die?
Like, I... okay, me and my chat's dead too.
I think it has to be OBS.
It has to be an OBS issue.
But I'll ask the chat coder.
To see if it's like... I'll ask the chat... the person who coded the chat to see if they know what's going on.
Alright.
Uh...
I need a rest.
Yeah.
Sleep tight!
Yay!
Alright, let's go.
You guys are so strong now!
Three battles!
Oh my god, I literally...
Wait!
If I lost that battle there, we would've died!
Yeah, we would've died!
I literally avoided canon event!
Wait, that's so funny!
I actually saved his life!
He was actually gonna die there!
That's actually so funny!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
That's so funny!
I can't believe I actually avoided his canon death!
Holy shit!
A canon event avoided!
I wanted to fish!
You guys did great!
You guys avoided the canon event!
We Spider-Man'd that shit!
You guys did amazing!
I still can't believe we actually avoided...
avoided it!
Where's the fishing?
I was told I can fish here!
Oh!
Let's go fishing!
Aww man!
Press A to try fishing...
to try choosing...
Okay, normal there.
How do I fish?
The fish comes...
The boy with twitch...
Press the polar...
If you try to do this before, fishing will be interrupted.
Okay.
Alright, press A with the right timing.
Where's the fish?
Oh!
Yay!
I got Digicarp!
Because it's not a real fish!
Oh, I can feed you guys!
Alright, level 2.
Oh my god!
Wizardmon is so strong!
Come on!
Go in there!
Jesus Christ!
I told you!
Tough love!
Works!
Holy shit!
Dragon 3, tough love works!
Dragon 3, look at you!
Now you're so strong!
Now you're actually so fucking strong!
Jesus Christ!
What the fuck?
What the fuck happened?
You learned how to defend this brother!
Oh shit, we gotta head home!
Is there no food?
I have food!
Ready?
Oh no.
What do you mean is there no food?
You think...
You think mama would mistreat you guys like this?
Okay, I need to make sure we're both being fed.
You don't like this?
It's okay.
It's okay if you don't like this.
Alright.
Let's see.
Time to eat!
Yay!
Alright, are you guys still hungry?
C'mon!
Don't worry, I have more meat.
Alright, I like how only uh...
I like how only ah...
Dragon 4 is happy.
Dragon 3 is just edgy as fuck.
Ahaha!
Uh...
Something delicious is here?
What is?
What's hopping?
Did you guys hear that?
Is it Gatomon?
Is Gatomon hopping?
Is that your sound?
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Speaking of food, please feed us and meal pets.
We're starving and dying of pox.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know what's funny?
I checked my inventory and so many people gifted me the medicine to cure Neopox.
Everybody was sending me the medicine to heal you guys.
And I... I didn't accept it.
I rejected the medicine.
Guys, I am trying to make sure you guys develop the right antibodies to fight off Neopox.
Chat.
If I just give you the medicine, then you're just never gonna develop the antibodies that will require you to fight it off.
You're just gonna be like a fucking bubble boy.
We're literally living the life of medieval peasants there.
You're literally in the hotel.
She's a natural medicine auntie.
No!
Okay, I'm gonna go... Okay, I'm gonna... I'm gonna... Okay, I'm gonna buy you the medicine.
I'm gonna buy you the medicine.
I'm gonna buy you the medicine, guys.
Alright, let's go to the gym.
Okay, you need to... You need more, I think, wisdom, right?
Alright, here we go.
No!
I failed it!
This is the first time I failed it!
Oh my god, this is actually the first time I've ever failed it.
Alright, time to train more.
You need speed as well?
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah!
Alright, sleepy time.
Sleep in the gym.
Sleepy time.
Yeah!
Some good sleep.
Alright, food time!
We're gonna eat food outside.
Cause mom doesn't have food anymore, so she gotta go to the soup kitchen.
Sorry, the meat kitchen.
Yay!
It's meat kitchen time!
Meat that grows from the ground.
Alright, let's see.
There you go.
You don't like that item?
It's okay.
It's okay to be picky.
You gotta have standards.
Yeah.
Anyway, eat it again.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
So like, when do they die?
How many days are they allowed to be alive?
I don't know if I want to see them die.
Like...
Oh, the age.
Oh, 14 days.
Oh, thank you.
Oh my god.
Okay.
14 days.
Okay, so technically, they can never die.
I can't believe it though.
I can't believe I actually...
I don't wanna digivolve them.
Alright, I think we'll call it here.
The fact that I saved wizard mod.
I can't believe I saved...
I don't want those guys to digivolve.
They're perfect!
They're actually perfect!
They're...
They're perfect as they are!
That's what I'm gonna call it here.
Oh my god.
That was really fun though.
I had a really fun time.
I still can't believe we got the cat.
We got Wizardmon and Gothamon.
I was not expecting Wizardmon at all.
I'm gonna save game.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I saved it.
I saved it.
I saved it guys.
Don't worry.
That's so funny though.
That I managed to get... and then I saved Wizardmon before he fucking got killed a third time.
You could...
He actually... it was this close.
It was actually this close that we could've got a Wizardmon death right after the digivolution.
Um...
The digibomb.
I can't believe it.
Um...
Kaz, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
We actually witnessed the origin story of OG Gothamon and Wizardmon right here.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Half a second.
If we... if we let it...
If we like hesitated for one more second, Wizardmon would've been gone.
He would've actually been gone.
Oh my god.
Guys, tough love made you so strong.
And now look at you!
You're even stronger than Gothamon!
That was crazy!
You literally like two shot...
You two shot people.
Uh...
Um...
Yeah, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Rule one... Oh wait, sorry.
I read that.
But thank you again.
Um...
Yeah, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Maybe Dragon 3 has only put in the same amount of work as the appreciation he received.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
That's really fun though.
I had a really fun time playing Digimon World.
I...
I do wish it was...
Um... It was more similar to the original Digimon World.
Because the original Digimon World was like much... I don't know if it's cause like I need to travel more.
I feel like the original Digimon World, you'd never...
You didn't really have to live in the gym that much.
I feel like...
I feel like the original Digimon World...
Yeah, you didn't have to live in the gym for that long.
You can actually explore much... explore more.
Wait, you did?
You actually did?
I don't remember.
I think it's cause... um...
Was it actually... the original was so much harder?
Oh, that's why my Digimon kept dying.
Oh...
That makes more sense now.
Cause I didn't play the...
I was like way too young to be playing that game.
And...
So that's why...
Okay, that makes a lot more sense now.
I was not training my Digimon in the gym.
I was just exploring the world.
I was triggering some like uh... game events too.
Cause like... uh... if you visit the beach at one point, like a monster comes up and takes you to the other side of the island.
And I remember stuff like that.
Oh, that's why my Digimon was so underpowered.
Oh my god.
Ha!
Next order is pretty much a cakewalk compared to the original.
Oh!
Okay.
I didn't realize like... you were supposed to live in the gym.
I literally was just exploring the world.
I thought the world building was really interesting.
I just remember the...
the world... um...
The world in Digimon World the original was like really interesting.
And like... I loved exploring around the environment cause I couldn't read cause it was all in Japanese.
But I loved like exploring the area and everything and like looking at the different uh... different Digimons uh... around the area.
Uh...
Anton!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Toughlove keeps retirement homes in business.
Toki!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Ha!
Um...
Um... but it was really fun!
I had a good time playing Digimon World with you guys.
Um...
I might have given some of you guys like...
PTSD.
Ha!
I might have given you guys some PTSD.
Um... but I had a great time.
I hope you guys had a great time too.
I hope you guys had a great time as well.
But in the end you got... you became Wizardmon in the end!
Chat!
You became Wizardmon!
Ha!
Lol, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Um...
But...
Um... I always have a great time streaming for you guys.
Um... I'm gonna head out cause we do have another stream today.
Uh... we do have GoodnightDragoons.
Um... and so I'm gonna spend more time there.
Uh... there to chat with you guys.
So I'm gonna call it here before... I don't wanna get too tired before... uh... the second stream.
Um... but thank you everybody for watching!
Thank you for coming!
As always everybody stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me head to bed cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!